Hey everybody, so we are here having another duo episode to talk about project planning, which is something that is super important. I think that there might be a dedicated class. I think at my college, there was a class called software engineering, but it was an elective and I never took it. But apparently, if you take, if you had taken that class, they actually cover project planning, but I had zero experience with project planning, you know, academic experience. And so, you know, it would have been awesome for
大家好，我们今天又录制了一期双人播客，来聊聊项目规划，这真的是一件超级重要的事情。我想大学里可能专门有这门课，我记得我上大学时，有一门课叫软件工程，但它是一门选修课，我从来没选过。但显然，如果你上过那门课，他们其实会讲项目规划，但我对项目规划可以说是零经验，你知道的，学术经验为零。所以，如果当时能有
me to have this episode or something like it. When I started, I feel like, um, um, it's something that, that is super, super important to make sure that you kind of follow through and also like so that you're not just overwhelmed mentally with everything that you're able to sort of, you know, keep a lot of these notes. So you don't have to kind of have a brain dump, you know? Yeah, I think I also missed that class. Yeah, it's all right. We'll make up for it today. Actually, I remember the reason I didn't take it was because they spent a huge chunk of the semester talking about UML. And I looked up UML on the Internet and I was like, no, no, I don't think I don't think I want to take this class.
这样一期播客或者类似的节目就好了。当我刚开始的时候，我觉得，这真的是一件超级、超级重要的事情，能确保你把事情贯彻到底，而且这样你就不会被各种事情搞得精神崩溃，能把这些笔记都好好保存下来。这样你就不需要经常去清空大脑了，对吧？是的，我想我也错过了那门课。好吧，没关系，我们今天把它补回来。其实，我记得我没选那门课的原因是，他们花了一个学期很大一部分时间在讲UML。我在网上查了一下UML，当时就觉得，不，不，我可不想上这门课。
Oh, man. That rings right up there with i looked up the teacher ratings and the teacher is rated as hard so i uh no i'm just i didn't say i did that just i hear people say that yeah i think uml was and i don't even it's gonna be very lucid here but i think it was some kind of diagramming thing where i remember there's like a picture of a person and the person goes into a flow chart and then i guess a happier person comes out or something. I don't know that the person goes into the flowchart. But it was enough.
天哪。这让我想起了那些我去查老师评分的时候，发现老师被评为“杀手”的情况，所以我就……呃，不，我只是开玩笑，我没这么干过，我只是听别人这么说。对，我想UML就是那种……现在脑子可能有点糊涂了，但我觉得它大概是一种画图的东西，我记得里面好像有一个小人的图片，小人走进一个流程图，然后我想会有一个更开心的小人走出来什么的。我不知道小人是不是真的走进了流程图。但总之这就够了。
UML is interesting. We should talk about it at some point. I mean, I think it's like the idea that is it unified or universal modeling language? I mean, like the idea for describing architecture that way is useful. But I think it had a heyday probably, yeah, the mid 2000s the aughts is that what they were calling them the zero axes anyways they're on that time where they thought they were going to like auto generate code or like you would go into the box and like type your code in the box and then it would uh get hooked up yeah oh i remember those auto code actually for, for GUI stuff. Auto code is
UML挺有意思的。我们应该找个机会聊聊它。我的意思是，我觉得它的理念是——它是叫统一还是通用建模语言？我的意思是，用那种方式来描述架构的理念是有用的。但它可能在全盛时期，大概是在2000年代中期，也就是俗称的“零零年代”或者随便叫什么名字的时候很火。总之，在那个时期，他们觉得自己可以自动生成代码，或者说你走进一个方框，在方框里输入你的代码，然后它就会自动连接起来。哦，我确实记得那些针对图形界面（GUI）的自动代码。
still quite nice. Like I used, what did I use recently? Oh yeah. I used the QT, QT designer, which is, is, is a, for a project I was doing, I wanted a cross-platform UI and I mean, oh man, we should definitely do a show on cross-platform UI because I spent so much time researching this. And usually it's not like me. I mean, one of the things we tell people on the show is to pick something and just stick to it. But I really couldn't find anything really that I wanted that was cross-platform that worked well. And finally settled on Qt. Initially, I was a little hesitant to use Qt
自动代码现在其实也挺不错的。比如我用过，我最近用了什么？哦，对。我用了Qt，Qt Designer，这是一个……在我做的一个项目中，我想要一个跨平台的界面，我的天，我们绝对应该做一期关于跨平台界面的节目，因为我花在研究这个上面的时间实在是太多了。这通常不太符合我的风格。我的意思是，我们在节目中经常告诉听众的一点是，随便选一个然后坚持下去。但我真的找不到任何我想要的、跨平台而且工作正常的工具。最后我决定用Qt。起初，我有点犹豫要不要用Qt
because it seemed pretty heavyweight and it has sort of Qt as its own style and all of that. But from a programming standpoint, Qt was really nice. And they have this thing called Qt Designer where it, you know, it auto generates Python code and then you go and fill in like when you click the button, what should happen. So for that, it works well but i think that you know yeah back when uml was getting really popular i think people had this vision that everything would all programming would work that way where you'd have this visual designer and then you would write like little bits of code in the designer and that's never really taken off other than that one use case actually there was something uh patrick you might you might remember this there was something where
因为它看起来挺笨重的，而且Qt有它自己的一套风格等等。但从编程的角度来看，Qt真的很棒。他们有个叫Qt Designer的东西，它能自动生成Python代码，然后你只需要去补充当按钮被点击时应该发生什么。所以从这方面来说，它用得很顺手。但我觉得，嗯，早在UML变得非常流行的时候，大家都有这样一种愿景，觉得所有的编程都会以那种方式进行：你会拥有一个可视化设计器，然后你会在设计器里写一点点代码，除了那一个特定用例之外，这种模式从来没有真正流行起来。其实还有一件事，帕特里克，你可能还记得，有一种东西
you could build like etl like data pipelines using this visual designer i think it's called a screwdriver or something but but you would like drag and drop blocks and then each block you would put in a bit of sql and then you would sort of like assemble these blocks of like sql and then each block you would put in a bit of SQL and then you would sort of like assemble these blocks of like SQL. And then one of the blocks could be, you know, right to this key value store or something like that. That actually was, I also thought that was pretty nice, but they ended up killing that project.
你可以用这种可视化设计器构建类似ETL的数据管道，我觉得它叫Screwdriver或者别的什么名字，但你可以通过拖放区块，然后在每个区块里写一点SQL，然后你就可以把这些SQL区块组装起来，然后在每个区块里写一点SQL，然后你就可以把这些SQL区块组装起来。接着其中一个区块可以是，你知道的，写入某个键值存储之类的。其实那也挺不错的，但他们最后把那个项目给砍了。
And I think what it was is the people who were much better at SQL and data engineering than I was hated it. So it was like, it was good for novices like me, but then somehow it was worse, a lot worse than just a text editor for the people who really know what they're doing. And maybe that's the general trend. Yeah, I don't know exactly what you're talking about. But it sounds vaguely familiar. I mean, I think there are places where specifically like the opposite is true, where describing the ETL pipeline that you describe in code with pictures as like an output documentation tool is still pretty widely used.
我想原因在于，那些比我更擅长SQL和数据工程的人非常讨厌它。所以它对像我这样的新手来说挺好，但不知怎么的，对于真正懂得他们在做什么的人来说，它比单纯的文本编辑器要糟糕得多，糟糕很多。也许这就是大体上的趋势吧。是的，我不太清楚你在说什么。但听起来有点耳熟。我的意思是，我觉得在某些地方情况正好相反，比如用图片作为输出文档工具来描述你在代码中编写的ETL管道，这种做法至今仍然被广泛使用。
Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. Cool. All right. So we're gonna dive into project planning. But first, let's talk a little bit about home NAS. So, you know, a lot of people have a lot of data at home now. I mean, I have, you know, a backup of all my photos. You know, I know Google Photos does, they change the resolution of the photo, right? So even though they'll store infinite, and actually, I think they're even, they're going to stop storing infinite. But anyways, so I just always keep a backup of all my photos and all sorts of other documents. I have a folder called Books. I have a folder called Research Papers.
对，对，这倒说得通。好的。那么我们接下来要深入探讨项目规划了。但首先，我们来聊聊家庭网络存储（NAS）。所以，你知道的，现在很多人家里都有大量的数据。我的意思是，我有所有照片的备份。你知道，我知道谷歌相册会改变照片的分辨率，对吧？所以即使它们会提供无限存储——其实，我想他们甚至准备停止提供无限存储了。不管怎样，我总是会保留我所有的照片以及各种其他文档的备份。我有一个叫“书籍”的文件夹。我有一个叫“研究论文”的文件夹。
It has like 90% content I've never read. It probably will never read, but it's there. We have a whole ton of information. We have Plex running, which Plex is a way to stream video within your house. And so all this data needs to be accessible and even ideally accessible outside your house with the right security, authentication, all of that. And what I used to do up until a week ago
里面大概有90%的内容我从来没读过。可能永远也不会读，但它就在那里。我们有海量的信息。我们运行着Plex，Plex是一种在家里流式传输视频的方式。所以所有这些数据都需要能被访问，理想情况下，在具备适当的安全认证等前提下，在家里外面也能访问。我以前的做法，直到一周前
was I used to just use the oldest desktop in the house. And so I had this desktop that I don't even know how old it is, maybe a decade old. And it has like a ton of hard drives in it. And it's barely able to run the latest Ubuntu, like it's just chugging along and trying to keep all of these hard drives up and running. And I had a drive failure. And so it really made me rethink, like, okay, what do I want to do here? What I ended up doing is similar. I ended up getting, there's this thing called a Yotta Master,
我以前只是用家里最老旧的那台台式机。所以我有一台台式机，我都不知道它有多老了，可能有一十年了吧。里面塞满了硬盘。它几乎快带不动最新的Ubuntu系统了，就像气喘吁吁地在维持所有这些硬盘的运转。然后我的一个硬盘坏了。这真的让我重新思考，好吧，我在这里到底想做什么？我最终采取的做法类似。我买了一个叫YottaMaster的东西，
but it's basically a hardware RAID enclosure. So you plug USB into your computer and then the other end is this enclosure, which has, I think mine has five drives in it, and it does RAID 5 in hardware. So from your view, it's just like plugging in a USB drive, but it's actually this five drive monstrosity. And so you just get this like, I don't know, I think it like 12 terabyte usb drive is kind of how it looks to the computer and so i have that plugged into a raspberry pi so that's that's my new setup but uh but yeah what do you have patrick i have actually like an old proper was it synology nas that uh i got from someone um that didn't want anyone was like, oh, there's I've used that before.
但它基本上是一个硬件RAID硬盘柜。所以你把USB插到电脑上，另一端就是这个硬盘柜，里面——我想我的里面有五个盘，它在硬件上做RAID 5。所以从你的角度来看，就像是插上了一个USB硬盘，但它实际上是个由五个硬盘组成的庞然大物。所以你得到的就好像是一个，我不知道，我觉得看起来就像是一个12太字节的USB硬盘。所以我把它插在树莓派上，这就是我的新配置。不过，帕特里克，你的是什么？我其实有一个老旧的、正儿八经的群晖（Synology）NAS，是从别人那里拿来的，因为那个人不想要了，当时就有人说……哦，我以前用过那个。
And, you know, also, interestingly, and depending on your backup strategy, I mean, we have a similar thing, like backing up to the various cloud small parts of our data that's like super important, like, you know, pictures and documents and stuff. And then for larger stuff, what i've done between various computers is uh we've talked about on the show before i think it used to be bt sync but now it's resilient sync and so it it kind of mirrors over time between computers and even like some of the stuff that's like family important to like my brothers or my father or whatever we have one of those folders between computers so like some of the stuff that i put there and they put there as well and then it backs up multiple sites right
而且，有趣的是，根据你的备份策略，我的意思是，我们也有类似的做法，比如把一小部分超级重要的数据备份到各种云端，比如照片和文档之类的。至于比较大的文件，我在不同的电脑之间做的是——我们以前在节目里聊过，以前叫BTSync，但现在叫Resilio Sync，所以它会随着时间在多台电脑之间进行镜像同步。甚至连一些对我的兄弟、父亲或其他人来说具有家族重要性的文件，我们在多台电脑之间也有这样一个文件夹。所以有些我放进去的东西，他们也会放进去，然后它会在多个站点进行备份，对吧？
so like as long as if not both of our houses were taken out by some catastrophe in theory some of that data would be recoverable but also what i've come to realize is like a lot of stuff that i was backing up even if like hard drives are cheap it's just like it's not worth it it's kind of like storing stuff in your house like oh it's cheap to buy these clothes I'll just buy more and more clothes but then you need bigger closets and you run out of space and you start being compelled to buy a bigger house I think oh it is at Marie Kondo yeah that's right I don't know that story but yeah digital Marie Kondo I think the same thing is true like I don't need to back up my entire Steam library like whatever Steam has its own issue I don't wantie condo i think the same thing is true like i don't need to back up my entire steam
所以只要不是我们的两座房子同时被某种灾难摧毁，理论上其中一些数据是可以恢复的。但我也开始意识到，我备份的很多东西，即使硬盘很便宜，也根本不值得备份。这就有点像在家囤东西：哦，买这些衣服很便宜，那我就越买越多，结果你需要更大的衣橱，空间不够了，最后你甚至被迫去买更大的房子。我想……哦，这不就是近藤麻理惠（Marie Kondo）嘛！对，没错。我不懂那个故事，但对，数字版的近藤麻理惠。我觉得同样的道理也适用于此，我不需要备份我的整个Steam游戏库，不管Steam有什么自己的问题，我不想……数字版的近藤麻理惠，我觉得同样的道理也适用于此，我不需要备份我的整个Steam
library like whatever steam has its own issue i don't want to even get into that but like if i have a steam game and the steam game is really big like part of having bought it on steam is the ability of like re-downloading it and you can get into your own like do you really own it or not but for me personally what i've just made that decision is like i don't need my all my games backed up because i can just redownload them if something were to happen and basically that can cut out a ton same thing like i don't need to back up core windows or even windows settings anymore like a lot of that stuff now the folders that have like documents in them yes but all the other stuff like settings like look worst case
游戏库，不管Steam有什么自己的问题，我甚至都不想深入讨论这个。但如果我有一个Steam游戏，而且这个游戏非常大，那么在Steam上购买它的一部分价值就在于你可以重新下载它。你可能会陷入“你到底是不是真的拥有它”这种讨论中，但就我个人而言，我做出的决定是：我不需要备份所有的游戏，因为如果发生什么事，我可以直接重新下载它们。基本上这可以省下大量空间。同样的道理，我不再需要备份核心Windows甚至Windows设置了。现在很多这类东西，包含文档的文件夹是要备份的，但所有其他东西，比如设置——你看，最坏的情况
i'll just build that back up myself and so what i do is i do make like for certain of those things like clones locally on that computer but for the most part like i just will reinstall and then bring back the data that matters and yeah that would kill a lot of time but it's the expectedness of it right like it would take a catastrophic hard drive failure which can happen and does happen but what is it going to happen during like my usage pattern it's like maybe once every x years five years four years and like reinstalling with to be honest is probably better than just like bringing forward all of that debris yeah yeah totally agree yeah that's a really good call out you know when i look at my nas i mean it has a lot of books i thought i would read and things like that but but i'm the same as you i don't put games on there i feel like anything i could read download
我自己把它重新配置好就行了。所以我的做法是，对于某些东西，我会在那台电脑上在本地做一些克隆。但大部分情况下，我只会重新安装，然后把重要的数据恢复回来。是的，这会浪费很多时间，但这也是可以预料的，对吧？这需要经历一次灾难性的硬盘故障，这种事确实会发生，但在我的使用模式下，它什么时候会发生呢？也许每隔X年、五年、四年发生一次。说实话，重新安装可能比把所有那些陈旧的垃圾都迁移过来要好。是的，完全同意。这真的是个很好的痛点。你知道，当我看看我的NAS时，里面有很多我以为自己会读的书之类的内容。但我跟你一样，我不会把游戏放在上面。我觉得任何我可以重新下载的东西，
um you know i don't really have on there i mean i guess i could re-download the books and the research papers but it's more just like like uh i always feel like oh one of these days i'll i'll need to know like what are all the graph theory research papers i've ever looked up um so it's more of just like a personal archive yeah that's a great point though like i i feel similar and it's same thing with like my bookmarks like i constantly have not a good way to like bookmark things and like keep them organized it's just like right now i have like a billion tabs open and a tab is like a lightweight bookmark and there's like short-term long-term memory like substance short-term
嗯，我真的不会放在上面。我的意思是，我想我可以重新下载书籍和研究论文，但它更多就像是一个……我总是觉得，哦，总有一天我需要知道我查过的所有图论研究论文是什么，所以它更多只是一个个人档案。是的，不过这真是一个极好的观点。我有同感，这就像我的书签一样，我总是找不到一个好方法来给东西加书签并保持井井有条，目前我就是开了一亿个标签页，标签页就像是一个轻量级的书签，里面有短期和长期记忆的区别，比如短期……
occasion i want it to automatically go into long term and it's just because searching the internet for an obscure graph theory paper i don't read graph theory let's pretend i did like then you know searching is really quite difficult sometimes and this has happened to me like i don't know that it's important until kind of it's too late so having like a history of what you looked at or whatever and for like you books or whatever, what you're talking about is you want to save the curation of them, but like the data itself is not that interesting. But all of us fall into these traps
偶尔我希望它能自动进入长期记忆，只是因为在互联网上搜索一篇晦涩难懂的图论论文非常困难——我不研究图论，假设我研究过好了——有时候搜索确实相当困难。这种情况发生在我身上过：在你意识到它很重要之前，你根本不知道它重要。所以保留你浏览过的内容的历史记录，或者对于你的书籍什么的，你所说的其实是你想保存对它们的整理归纳，但数据本身并不是那么有趣。不过我们所有人都会陷入这些陷阱，
that like the tools just aren't there yet to model that. I mean, people will probably write us and tell us some good tips. Yeah, definitely. But I mean, I think like what you're saying is even just having a recording of the file names of your file folders, which is of course very lightweight, has a lot of the value of actually recording the data, but it's just easier to record the data. Yeah. So I think that the big reasons
那就是工具还不足以对这种行为进行建模。我的意思是，人们可能会写信给我们，提供一些好建议。是的，绝对的。但我的意思是，我觉得就像你说的，甚至只是记录你的文件和文件夹的文件名——这当然非常轻量，它拥有实际记录数据的大部分价值，而且记录起来更容易。是的。所以我觉得，对 NAS 来说最大的理由
for a NAS for me are pictures and videos. So, you know, we don't have, I don't think, well, actually I take it back. We definitely have some way to play DVDs in this house. I don't know what it is. I mean, it's probably in a box somewhere like an old PlayStation or something. Yeah. But, you know, we have all of the DVDs have been have been ripped, you know, even like the DVD of our wedding and everything. All of that is ripped and on the on the NAS and then and then all of our pictures are
对我而言是照片和视频。所以，我们没有，我觉得……其实我收回前言。我们家里绝对有某种可以播放DVD的设备。我不知道是什么。我的意思是，它可能在某个盒子里，比如一台旧的PlayStation什么的。是的。不过，我们所有的DVD都已经抓取转换了，甚至连我们婚礼的DVD之类的所有东西。所有这些都已经被抓取并存放在NAS上，然后我们所有的照片也都在
on the NAS. If it wasn't for those two, then I would probably just run Resilio Sync on all the computers in the house. I mean, I have that as well. And so actually this is an interesting question is do you use Resilio Sync or Dropbox for personal things? I feel like I'm kind of using both. And sometimes I wonder like, yeah, I mean,
NAS上。如果不是为了这两样东西，我可能就会在家里所有的电脑上运行Resilio Sync了。我的意思是，我也有这个。所以这其实是一个有趣的问题：你在处理个人事务时使用的是Resilio Sync还是Dropbox？我觉得我两种都在用。有时我在想，是的，我的意思是，
like is somebody gonna hack my dropbox and get forms with my address on them or something yeah i mean look people will get your social security number or your tax returns or whatever and commit very targeted fraud against you like i i mean it's the same thing like if this gets really depressing if someone decides to rob your house specifically they will watch it they will decide when you're not home. They will decide what's in it and what they're going to grab, right? And then to defend against that is very difficult. What you're looking for is defending against someone just like getting onto your computer
会不会有人黑进我的Dropbox，然后拿到写有我地址的表格之类的东西？是的，听着，人们可以拿到你的社会安全号或纳税申报单什么的，然后针对你进行非常有针对性的诈骗。我的意思是，这就像——如果这个话题变得非常令人沮丧的话——如果有人决定专门抢劫你的房子，他们会观察你，他们会决定你不在家的时候动手。他们会决定里面有什么以及他们要抢走什么，对吧？要防范这一点是非常困难的。你要防范的其实是有人通过某种零日漏洞蠕虫侵入你的计算机，
with some zero-day worm and encrypting your computer and then trying to blackmail you and a 1000 other people that like, you know, pay or we're going to keep it encrypted, right? Like, could they do that? Yeah. And then what you're talking about is unless they the NAS is good, because it's probably a completely different stack than your desktop. So the chance of it sharing a zero day, although recently, a lot of the NAS has had a really nasty vulnerability where they could get wiped. so i think like the synology ones or something so yeah so be careful i mean i think that yeah i think that dropbox like i totally agree with you that if someone's targeting you personally and for whatever reason they like just really want to get you and they're willing to fish
加密你的计算机，然后试图勒索你和其他一千个人，说“付钱，否则我们就让它一直保持加密状态”，对吧？他们能做到吗？是的。而这就是NAS的优势所在，因为它使用的技术栈可能与你的台式机完全不同。所以它和一个零日漏洞共享漏洞的几率很低，尽管最近很多NAS都有非常严重的漏洞，可能会导致数据被清空。所以我想像群晖之类的设备……是的，所以要小心。我的意思是，是的，我觉得Dropbox……我完全同意你的看法，如果有人在针对你个人，出于某种原因他们真的非常想整你，并且愿意对你进行网络钓鱼
you and do all these things and you're you're in spot. But for all of us who are just normal dudes, I think that it's really the concern is that Dropbox somehow gets hacked in a way where everyone's Dropbox. But then I guess, you know, I guess to follow that train of thought, if everyone's Dropbox was leaked, my Dropbox is probably not high priority. Like in other words, like like seeing seeing forms, like, like medical forms from like a hospital bill with my address or something is not what they really want to see. They probably want, you know, I don't know, tax returns or something, but yeah. So, so, you know, I guess I have a mixture of Resilio sync, which is syncing among all the computers, similar to
并做所有这些事情，那你确实在劫难逃。但对于我们所有只是普通人的人来说，我认为真正需要担心的是Dropbox以某种方式被黑客入侵，导致所有人的Dropbox数据泄露。但我想，顺着这个思路想下去，如果所有人的Dropbox都被泄露了，我的Dropbox可能优先级不高。换句话说，看到诸如来自医院账单的写有我地址的医疗表格之类的东西，并不是他们真正想看的。他们可能想要的是，我不知道，纳税申报单之类的东西。所以，你知道的，我大概是混用了Resilio Sync（它在所有电脑之间同步）和类似的东西
Patrick. I have it also syncing with my folks' computers. And then I have the NAS for the pictures. We've just terabytes of pictures and DVDs and all of that. And yeah, it seems to work pretty well. I debated getting the Synology, but I felt like I already have several Raspberry Pis that run 24-7. I kind of felt like I might as well,
帕特里克。我还让它与我父母的电脑进行同步。然后我有用来存放照片的网络附加存储（NAS）。我们有数TB的照片、DVD以及所有这些东西。是的，它似乎运作得相当不错。我曾考虑过买一台群晖，但我觉得自己已经有几个全天候运行的树莓派了。我某种程度上觉得，不如就直接……
you know, installing Plex on Ubuntu is pretty, or on, I guess, Debian for Raspberry Pi is pretty easy. So I went that route, but I'd be curious, folks at home, or actually, Patrick, I mean, like, how would you think a Synology compares to just like running an Ubuntu machine? I mean, better and worse. It's a more appliance approach. So it's not the, I'm uploading everything to Google and subject to the whims of their terms and conditions or whatever. Like you'd normally, it's sort of your box.
你知道的，在Ubuntu上安装Plex相当……或者说，我猜在树莓派的Debian上安装相当简单。所以我走了这条路。不过我很好奇，家里的各位，或者说帕特里克，我的意思是，你觉得群晖和仅仅运行一台Ubuntu机器相比怎么样？我是说，各有利弊。它更像是一个一体化的设备方案。所以它不是那种我把所有东西都上传到谷歌、受制于他们服务条款变迁之类的东西。就像你通常会做的那样，这基本上是你自己的盒子。
So there's some level you could pull the hard drive off and like mount it on your own computer, worst case or whatever. A Boon Juizag is nice, but then you gotta like, there's time spent like updating it, choosing what to install, getting it to an, there's stuff but then you gotta like there's time spent like updating it choosing what to install getting it to and there's stuff like you know talk about like unraid or free nests or is it open nests which are more tailored to you know having a samba share so if you want to like mount it from windows or whatever which is stuff that sort of synology would come out of
所以某种程度上，最坏的情况下你可以把硬盘拆下来，装到你自己的电脑上。Ubuntu当然不错，但接着你得花时间去更新它、选择安装什么、让它运行起来，而且有些事情……接着你得花时间去更新它、选择安装什么、让它运行起来，而且有些事情，你知道的，比如Unraid、FreeNAS或者OpenNAS，它们更适合用来提供Samba共享，所以如果你想从Windows挂载它之类的，这正是群晖开箱即用就能……
the box you can figure all that out absolutely in fact, probably build a much more capable machine for cheaper unless you factored in how much time you spend on it and put any value on that time. Yeah, that's a really, really good call out. Yeah, I think as someone who'd already done a lot of Samba and all these things and that was incremental.
你完全可以自己把所有这些弄明白。事实上，如果你不把花在上面的时间以及时间的价值计算在内，你可能会花更少的钱造出一台功能更强大的机器。是的，这真的是一个非常非常好的点。是的，我觉得作为一个已经做过很多Samba和所有这些事情的人来说，那只是增量工作。
But yeah, you're right. If I was just starting out and I had a Linux machine and I needed Windows to see the hard drives and all of that, I mean, that is like weeks to get that right and actually have it be really smooth and work when the machine starts and everything. But that's not why. I mean, most of this is a hobby and it has a vague, in theory, help to our careers longer term by staying up on tech and learning new things and being in that space. So yeah, that's a good call. So maybe, okay, here's our advice. So if we were to, if we were to sort of conclude with advice for people who want to set up a home NAS, maybe you have a
但是的，你说得对。如果我是刚开始接触，有一台Linux机器，又需要让Windows能识别硬盘以及所有这些，我的意思是，这简直需要花好几周时间才能弄对，并真正让它运行顺畅、开机自启以及一切正常。但这并不是原因。我的意思是，这大部分只是一个爱好，理论上它通过跟上技术、学习新东西以及身处那个领域，能对我们的长远职业生涯有微弱的帮助。所以是的，这个观点很好。那么，好吧，这是我们的建议。所以如果我们用对想搭建家庭NAS的人的建议来做个总结，也许你有一台……
desktop. So, you know, in my case, you know, I lost a hard drive in this machine and also the processor fan went out. And so the machine won't boot because it actually, it's interesting, it'll boot, but then it won't restart because the processor gets so hot that the BIOS won't let you continue. So like I had to shut it off, wait for the processor to cool down and then turn it back on. So I lost the hard drive. The processor is dead on this thing. Oh yeah, but I had a RAID. So it was RAID 1 or whatever. So I didn't actually lose any data. But if you have everything running just on your desktop and you have all the things you've ever programmed in your whole life, some of that stuff's sentimental or you might have pictures or other things. Definitely think about getting some kind of NAS setup. It could be as simple as
台式机。所以，你知道，就我而言，我这台机器坏了一块硬盘，而且CPU风扇也坏了。所以机器无法启动，因为实际上——这很有趣——它能启动，但随后无法重启，因为CPU太热了，BIOS不允许你继续。所以我不得不关机，等CPU冷却下来后再打开。所以我丢了一块硬盘。这东西的CPU死翘翘了。哦，对，但我有个RAID。所以是RAID 1之类的。所以我实际上并没有丢失任何数据。但如果你所有的东西都只在台式机上运行，而且你拥有你这辈子编写过的所有东西，其中有些东西很有纪念意义，或者你可能有照片或其他东西。一定要考虑买某种NAS设置。它可能很简单，就是……
just putting more hard drives into your computer. If you don't have a lot of time, I think Synology, I know several people who have Synology and like it, but I definitely think something like that would be really important. You should check into it. If you want to put in the time and effort, I think getting a Ubuntu or Debian or getting a Linux box connected to a bunch of hard drives is, for me at least, it's been the way to go. Agreed. All right. So jumping into news, my first news story is this pretty cool thing. It's a homebrew CNC machine. Patrick, what does CNC stand for? I don't actually know. Computer Numerical Control. And so what that means to me, and maybe i'm totally wrong here is it's basically like a drill like a drill that you could control
在电脑里加装更多的硬盘。如果你没有太多时间，我觉得群晖——我知道有几个人有群晖并且很喜欢——但我绝对觉得类似那样的东西非常重要。你应该了解一下。如果你愿意投入时间和精力，我觉得弄一个Ubuntu、Debian或者弄一台连接了一堆硬盘的Linux主机，对我来说至少是最佳选择。赞同。好的。那么进入新闻环节，我的第一个新闻是一个非常酷的东西。这是一个自制的CNC机器。帕特里克，CNC代表什么？我其实不知道。计算机数字控制。对我而言，这意味着——也许我完全理解错了——它基本上就像是一个钻头，一个你可以用计算机控制的……
with a computer and you could you can like carve things out and did i get that right how would you explain this no a mill it's normally a mill so it's normally like so the difference a drill is uh braced to only go like up and down, not side to side. So no side loading. So it has bearings meant to allow you to push into a material, but not drag through a material. Versus a router is a machine that is braced with bearings on the side. So if you drag it across the material and they're side loading,
钻头，你可以用它雕刻东西。我理解得对吗？你觉得该怎么解释？不对，铣床。通常是铣床。所以两者的区别在于，钻头被固定为只能上下移动，不能左右移动。所以没有侧向负载。因此它的轴承是为了让你能够压入材料而设计的，但不是为了在材料中拖拽。而雕刻机（Router）则是一种在侧面有轴承固定的机器。所以如果你把它拖过材料并且有侧向负载，
that's like engineered for it. And so a mill or a CNC is, it used to be a mill was these things with like handles and screwdrives and like you would twist various knobs and move and shave stuff down and that's how most like heavy machinery is still built this cnc i assume you're talking about haven't looked at it yet is like a router that can go up and down but doesn't apply a lot of up and down force but then side to side is braced so that you can go through a material and like hog it out and it won't break the internals of either the thing that's moving the motor around or the motor itself. So you're saying if I, and this shows how little I understand
那正是为它设计的。所以铣床或CNC——以前的铣床是那种带把手和螺丝刀的东西，你要转动各种旋钮来移动和削减材料，这也是大多数重型机械目前的制造方式。我猜你说的这个CNC，我还没看，就像是一个能上下移动但不施加太多上下力的雕刻机，但它的左右两侧是固定加固的，这样你就可以穿过材料并将其挖空，而不会损坏移动马达的部件或马达本身。所以你是说如果我——这也说明我对机械的东西了解得有多少。
mechanical stuff. So you're saying if I took like a drill, like a power drill and I tried to go, well, I'd need a special bit bit let's say i had a bit that had blades on the side or something and i tried to like go sideways with the drill it would like break the drill because it's like not meant for not immediately okay but it would do damage yeah the basically like the bearings and the internal structure isn't meant for side loading got it so it's sturdy but if you did it, continue, it's more what happens is people try to do it on their drill press. So if you have a drill press and you're trying to move the material under the drill press constantly, and you give it too much, you're going to, it's not going to like catastrophically break. It's called a runout,
所以你是说如果我拿一个电钻，比如手电钻，然后我试着去……好吧，我需要一个特殊的钻头，比方说我有一个侧面带刃的钻头，然后我试图用电钻横向移动，它会弄坏电钻，因为它不是为……不是立刻坏，但会造成损害，对吧。基本上，轴承和内部结构不是为了侧向负载设计的。明白了，所以它很结实，但如果你继续这样做……更多的情况是人们试图在钻床（Drill press）上这样做。所以如果你有一个钻床，并且你试图不断地在钻床下方移动材料，而且你给它的力太大，你就会……它不会灾难性地损坏。这被称为径向跳动（Runout），
right? The amount of error there is in the concentricity of the spinning parts. So the spinning parts begin to wobble and the reason why is because you're putting pressure on a piece that isn't meant to take that load and so over time it deforms and then you get you know basically more error in the exact diameter of the thing that's spinning and when your computer controlling it there it's open loop so there's no closed loop which means it it tries to do a thing and it doesn't know if it accomplished the thing so that's open loop closed loop is you do a thing and then you take a measurement to see if you accomplish the thing you attempted to to change you attempted to
对吧？旋转部件同心度中存在的误差量。所以旋转部件开始晃动，原因是你对一个不承受这种载荷的部件施加了压力，随着时间推移它会变形，然后你就会知道，基本上旋转物体精确直径上的误差会更大。当你的计算机在控制它时，它是开环的，所以没有闭环，这意味着它试图做一件事，但它不知道自己是否完成了这件事，这就是开环。闭环是你做了一件事，然后进行测量，看看你是否完成了你试图改变的事情，你试图驱动的事情。
actuate so so this guy built his own cnc machine from scratch with like three parts and he got a uh there is like like inside of it all is this thing that you could buy i've actually seen it at home depot i think it's called a router or something but yeah yeah so so inside of all of this is like this cheap 30 router thing but then he's 3d printed all of this stuff around it and i think some of it you have to buy like you know timing belts and stuff and he's and and so he's end up with his own cnc machine which looks like pretty big i mean i looked into this at one point getting a tiny cnc machine is like at least a few hundred dollars and so with this it's like looks relatively cheap and you end up with a big cnc machine what's your take on this patrick
所以这家伙从零开始用大约三个零件搭建了自己的CNC机器，他弄了一个……里面有一个你可以买到的东西，我其实在全家（Home Depot）看到过，我想它叫雕刻机（Router）或者类似的东西，但对这一切的内部，是一个价值30美元的廉价雕刻机，但他用3D打印了它周围的所有东西，我想其中有些东西你必须购买，比如正时皮带之类的，他最后得到了他自己的CNC机器，看起来相当大。我的意思是，我曾经研究过这个，买一台微型CNC机器至少要几百美元，而这个看起来相对便宜，最后你还能得到一台大型CNC机器。帕特里克，你对此有何看法？
does this look like a good idea or just like a fun thing to do, but not a good idea? I mean, I've had one before. The one I had was a branded one, which the brand has sort of changed over time, called a Shape Oko. Oh, interesting. So it's more like a kit, but I'm looking at this now. Yes, that Makita router in the middle is meant for a human to hold and push through wood to shave wood sideways. So it's using the right got it these are like industrial ideas that are being made for the hobbyist if you have a need for so i had a shape oko which is the same idea as this when i had it when i was using it the
这看起来是个好主意，还是只是一个好玩但算不上好主意的事情？我的意思是，我以前有过一台。我曾经有的是一个品牌货，随着时间推移品牌名字换过，叫做Shapeoko。哦，很有意思。所以它更像是一个套件，但我现在正在看这个。是的，中间那个牧田（Makita）雕刻机是给人拿着用来推过木头以横向削木头的。所以它在利用正确的……明白了，这些都是为业余爱好者制造的工业级理念。如果你有这种需求——所以曾几何时我有一个Shapeoko，和这个理念一样，当我拥有它并使用它时，
issue is that like it kicks up a ton of sawdust. So if you don't normally do woodworking or used to 3D printing, they're relatively, like 3D printing is relatively clean. When you start to do like power tool woodworking, this bit is spinning super, super fast and it's throwing tiny bits of wood dust. This picture I'm looking on their website
问题在于它会激起大量的木屑。所以如果你平时不做木工活，或者只习惯3D打印，它们相对而言……3D打印相对来说比较干净。当你开始做这种电动工具木工活时，这个钻头旋转得非常非常快，并且会甩出微小的木屑。我正在看他们网站上的这张照片，
is they're carving MDF, which is basically sawdust glued together. So when you cut through it, it's remaking sawdust and blowing it into the air. I heard that MDF is toxic. It has formaldehyde in it. Yeah, right. And so, yeah, be careful with it.
他们正在雕刻MDF（中密度纤维板），这基本上就是用胶水粘在一起的锯末。所以当你切开它时，它会重新产生锯末并将其吹到空中。我听说MDF有毒。里面含有甲醛。是的，没错。所以，是的，使用时要小心。
But basically it's making sawdust that's going everywhere, tiny bits, and it's just flowing into the air. And so... So, wait, what do you do about that? Vacuum it up at the end. Oh, okay. Got it. Wear a dust mask.
但基本上它会产生到处飞扬的锯末，微小的颗粒，直接飘进空气中。所以……等等，你对此有什么对策？最后用吸尘器吸掉。哦，好的。明白了。戴上防尘口罩。
Okay. A lot of people try to put a cover around it that has a vacuum attached to it. But even then, the vacuum fills up pretty quickly. It's a sort of constant fight. I would say there's one, I think it's called the mostly printed CNC MP CNC. That one I have heard about a little bit more. There's a shape OCO which is like a consumer
好的。很多人试图在它周围做一个罩子，上面连接着一个吸尘器。但即便如此，吸尘器也很快就会装满。这可以说是一场持续的斗争。我想说有一个，我想它叫“主要由3D打印构成的CNC”（MPCNC）。那个我听说过一点。还有一个Shapeoko，它是一个消费级的……
grade. There's several other consumer grade CNCs as well. I mean, it's if you have a use for it, like cutting out thick pieces of wood or making a sculpture in the face or whatever is definitely a super interesting hobby to be in. So yeah, I mean, it's cool. Yeah, well, check it out. I think if you have the time, it's similar to building your own NAS. If you want to develop a skill and you have some time,
市面上还有好几款其他消费级的CNC。我的意思是，如果你有这方面的用途，比如切割厚木板，或者在表面雕刻雕塑之类的，绝对是一个超级有趣的爱好。所以，是的，这很酷。好吧，去看看吧。我觉得如果你有时间，这和自己组建NAS很像。如果你想培养一项技能而且有一些时间，
this is a really cool project. I maybe would start with building your own 3D printer. I've done that before. And as you can hear, I know very little about this stuff. And I was able to pull that off. So maybe start there. But if you've done that, if you've built your own 3D printer, this would be a cool next thing to do. And I think the video is really compelling.
这是一个非常酷的项目。我可能建议从自己组装一个3D打印机开始。我以前做过。正如你所听到的，我对这些东西知之甚少。而我还是把它搞定了。所以也许从那里开始。但如果你做过那些，如果你组装过自己的3D打印机，这将是接下来要做的很酷的事情。而且我觉得那个视频真的很有吸引力。
It does exactly what you'd want it to do. Yeah. I mean, the small size, I'm looking at Shapeoko now. They don't have the small one I had gotten. So they start much larger. But the ones that you used to make were four feet by eight feet. So they were meant to cut up like an entire sheet of plywood that you would get from Home Depot or whatever. But four feet by eight feet, most people don't have that much space in their garage.
它完全能实现你希望它做到的功能。是的。我的意思是，说到小尺寸，我正在看Shapeoko。他们已经没有我以前买过的那种小号的了。所以他们的起步尺寸要大得多。但你以前用来制作的是4英尺乘8英尺的。所以它们是用来切割你从Home Depot或别的地方买到的整张胶合板的。但4英尺乘8英尺，大多数人的车库里没有那么大的空间。
And that probably costs like thousands of dollars, right? Yeah, that's right. Yeah. How much would this cost? I haven't looked at the BOM, the bill of materials. I mean, the big expense is the stepper motors and the sort of like rails and the controller. But I mean, if I had to guess, probably like $500, $600 if you had to source it news. Yeah, that's what I was going to guess too.
那可能要花几千美元，对吧？是的，没错。是的。这要花多少钱？我没看过BOM（物料清单）。我的意思是，大笔开销是步进马达、各种导轨和控制器。但如果要我猜的话，如果你自己去采购零件，大概要500到600美元左右。是的，我也是这么猜的。
Again, cool hobby. So related actually unintentionally, but in a bit vaguely, related to a CNC machine is when CNC machines make cuts, you need to make curves through the wood to make your beautiful shaped electric guitar that you're carving out, or even a surface. And if you were to look into modeling that surface, you might run across something called NURBS or Bezier curves. Oh, I've heard of that. Yeah. So there was recently an article by, I am not going to attempt to say the person's name, Bartosz Cichnowski. There's a link in the show notes. There's a link in the show notes. That's right. It's called Curves and Surfaces.
再次说明，这是一个很酷的爱好。无意中但又有些模糊地与CNC机器相关的是，当CNC机器进行切割时，你需要在木头上做出曲线，来打造你正在雕刻的形状优美的电吉他，甚至是某个表面。如果你想研究如何对该表面进行建模，你可能会遇到被称为NURBS或贝塞尔曲线（Bezier curves）的东西。哦，我听说过这个。是的。所以最近有一篇文章，我不打算尝试去读这个人的名字，Bartosz Cichnowski。节目文稿里有一个链接。节目文稿里有链接。没错。它叫做《曲线与表面》（Curves and Surfaces）。
And so he walks through and this guy's done a number of articles check out all the articles on his site he always has like a bunch of really really good interactive visualizations and so he starts through sort of like first principles of linear interpolations between two points and then what if you did that at like had two line segments segments that were, you know, of course, drawn by a linear interpolation between them. But what if you had, you know, instead of going between the points, you draw a line that connects an interpolation between the points and then a line that connects that line. And that's how you end up defining Bezier curves. Wow, this is cool. It's very interactive. Yes. And then if you start defining curves, then you could define surfaces and patches and, you know, provide smoothing on the derivatives, the first derivative or second derivative and what the impacts of that would be. And what would it mean to have kinks or, you know, sharp surfaces? And how would you handle that? goes it's actually rather if you make it through all of this and sort of really internalize all of it you will have a very good understanding of how a lot of modeling is done how a lot of 3d graphics is done this is so freaking cool you guys have got to go on this website i'm on it on my phone
所以他进行了详细的讲解，这家伙写过好几篇文章，去看看他网站上的所有文章吧，他总是有很多非常非常棒的交互式可视化内容。所以他从线性插值的基本原理开始讲起——两点之间的插值，然后如果你这样做会有什么效果，比如有两个线段，当然它们是通过两点之间的线性插值绘制的。但如果你有……不是在点之间穿梭，而是画一条线来连接点之间的插值，然后再画一条连接那条线的线。这就是你最终定义贝塞尔曲线的方式。哇，这太酷了。它是完全交互式的。是的。然后如果你开始定义曲线，你就能定义曲面和补丁（patches），并在导数、一阶导数或二阶导数上进行平滑处理，以及这样做会产生什么影响。存在折角或尖锐曲面意味着什么？你又该如何处理？事情的走向是——实际上，如果你通读了所有这些并真正内化了这一切，你将对许多建模是如何完成的、许多3D图形是如何制作的有非常好的理解。这实在是太酷了，你们一定要去这个网站。我现在正用手机在看，
here and even on the phone actually the phone is probably even better because of the touch screen but it is so freaking satisfying to play with these curves. So this is how like these curves that he ends up talking about is used like how Pixar like models the characters. Like if you want to model someone's nose, right? A nose isn't made of a bunch of triangles. A nose is made out of, you know, a sort of elastic material skin draped over a substructure of muscles and cartilage and whatever. Anyway, so you have to have an organic shape. And so that organic shape, you need a good way of sort of defining it. Eventually, you might end up reducing it to triangles.
而且甚至在手机上——实际上手机可能更好，因为有触摸屏——玩弄这些曲线简直太爽了。所以这就是他最后谈到的这些曲线的用途，比如皮克斯（Pixar）是如何为角色建模的。如果你想为一个人的鼻子建模，对吧？鼻子不是由一堆三角形组成的。鼻子是由一种弹性材料——皮肤——包裹在肌肉、软骨和其他结构的底层骨架上构成的。无论如何，你必须有一个有机形状。所以对于这个有机形状，你需要有一个好的方式来定义它。最终，你可能会把它简化为三角形。
But anyway, so this is really interesting. This comes up depending on, obviously, like what part of computer science you're in. But if you do much with graphics or rendering or even fonts how fonts are rendered fonts are defined using these bezier curves so how you define the like curve on the bottom of the s shape right like you define that in these bezier curves so most all fonts are defined using these style of things so it's actually used pretty heavily even if you kind of don't know it and you might run across it there have been recently a bunch more like very easy to understand interpretations of this. Prior to that,
不过不管怎样，这个真的很有趣。很明显，这会根据你所处的计算机科学领域而有所不同。但如果你经常接触图形、渲染，甚至字体——字体的渲染方式、字体的定义——它们都是用这些贝塞尔曲线定义的，比如你如何定义S形状底部的曲线，对吧？——你就是用这些贝塞尔曲线来定义的，所以绝大多数字体都是用这种风格的东西定义的，所以其实即使你可能并不了解它，它也被广泛使用，你可能也会偶然遇到它。最近出现了很多更容易理解的解释。在此之前，
you would have mostly gone to a computer graphics book and tried to read, and it would have given you a lot of math and a lot of linear algebra and said, here you go, here's how you define them. And if that's not your background, you would have been like, I don't get any of this. So explaining it in sort of layman's terms really helps you at least when you go into Inkscape and you're dragging the handles on the curve defining, you understand like what it's doing or why it loops back on itself, like at a fundamental level, like what is the computer trying to do? So I definitely recommend people sort of go and check it out. If nothing else, I'm like the cool graphics and learning a little bit more about like,
你多半会去翻一本计算机图形学书并试图阅读，它会给你一大堆数学和线性代数，然后说：“给你，这就是它们的定义方式。”如果这不是你的背景，你就会觉得：“我完全看不懂。”所以用通俗易懂的语言来解释它真的很有帮助，至少当你在Inkscape中拖动定义曲线的手柄时，你会从根本上理解它在做什么，或者为什么它会自我闭环，计算机到底想做什么？所以我强烈推荐大家去了解一下。退一步讲，我觉得那些酷炫的图形，以及多了解一点——
I don't know, like maybe fundamental is overstating it, but like a very like core piece of a lot of modern rendering and graphics and design. Yeah, totally. I mean, this is really, really fun to play with and it'll give you a really good understanding of, you know, yeah, how 3D geometry really works and it'll give you a really good understanding of you know yeah how 3d geometry really works and it'll connect the thing i love about this too is is it actually there's parts of it where it shows you an equation and as you are dragging these points around there's updating the equations in real time and so you can kind of in your brain you can like create synesthesia
我不知道，也许说它是基础有点夸张，但它确实是许多现代渲染、图形和设计中非常核心的一部分。是的，完全同意。我的意思是，这个玩起来真的非常非常有趣，它能让你真正很好地理解，你知道的，没错，3D几何体究竟是如何工作的，它能让你真正很好地理解，你知道的，没错，3D几何体究竟是如何工作的，而且它还会把——我喜欢的一点是，它实际上有些地方会向你展示一个方程式，当你拖动这些点时，它会实时更新方程式，所以在你的脑海里，你可以建立一种联觉，
between like this mathematics and then what's actually happening in this, in this picture. Super cool, man. Okay. So mine is also kind of a visual presentation, which is cool. We have amazing flow. This is, this might be our fastest flowing, cleanest flowing episode. Mine's a visual explanation of raft consensus protocol. So you have this issue where, you know, we were talking about your NAS at home and having RAID storage and so storing things on multiple hard drives. And that's not hard to do because you have this one USB cable or you have this one backplane on your motherboard, right? So there are all these hard drives are ultimately being controlled by one computer. But if you go to like, let's, a database at a really popular website, like take Amazon or something,
在这些数学原理和这个图片实际发生的情况之间。太酷了，伙计。好的。所以我的也是一种视觉演示，这很酷。我们今天的节奏太棒了。这可能是我们节奏最快、最流畅的一期节目。我的是关于Raft共识协议的视觉解释。所以你有这样一个问题，你知道的，我们之前讨论过你家里的NAS，以及拥有RAID存储，也就是把东西存储在多个硬盘上。这并不难做到，因为你有一根USB线，或者你的主板上有一个背板，对吧？所以所有这些硬盘最终都是由一台计算机控制的。但是如果你去看，比如，一个非常热门网站的数据库，比如亚马逊什么的，
they can't just have one computer controlling everyone's shopping cart. And so they need to have this massively distributed, fault-tolerant database. But then they also have to have like many different, what they call leaders, you know, places where you can write data. And then also have many followers, places where you could, servers where you could read data that you can't write to them. And so, you know, you have this huge array of leaders and followers and, because it's so large, let's say it's like 10,000 machines. And if a hard drive lasts three years, then you could do the math.
它们不可能只用一台计算机来控制每个人的购物车。因此，它们需要拥有这种大规模分布式、容错的数据库。但同时，它们也必须拥有许多不同的、被称为领导者的东西，你知道的，可以写入数据的机器。然后还要有许多跟随者，也就是你可以读取数据但不能向其写入数据的服务器。所以，你知道的，你拥有一个由领导者和跟随者组成的庞大阵列，而且，因为它的规模如此之大，比方说有1万台机器。如果一个硬盘能用三年，那么你就可以算一下，
But there's hard drives failing all the time in these machines. And there's other sorts of failures happening. And so you could have situations where even leaders fail. And now new leaders have to be elected. So imagine you expect to have three leaders. One of the leaders has failed. And so you now need to make one of your followers promoted to be a leader. All the followers are running the exact same code. You know, how do you do that? And, you know, if you could, you could imagine like heuristics, like, okay, let's have
但这些机器中的硬盘总是在坏。还有其他各种各样的故障在发生。所以你可能会遇到连领导者都发生故障的情况。现在必须选举出新的领导者。想象一下，你期望有三个领导者。其中一个领导者故障了。所以你现在需要让你的一个跟随者晋升为领导者。所有的跟随者运行的都是完全相同的代码。你知道，你该怎么做？而且，你知道，如果你可以的话，你可以想象一些启发式的方法，比如，好吧，让我们让
everyone report their IP address and pick the lowest one or something like that. But any type of heuristic like that will cause you to have sort of catastrophic failures. Like imagine a subnet goes down and now it's like really confusing for everybody. And so someone a long time ago came up with Paxos and it's a way for machines to negotiate with each other without a lot of a priori information. And so eventually, you know, there is something that breaks ties. It could be as simple as just like the fact that the processors are not exactly doing the same thing and they're not deterministic. Right. So there's a way to break ties. But more importantly, there's a way to achieve consensus. So like once you have some way that ties are broken, can you use this tie breaking to eventually pick one single leader when all the followers raise their hand at the same time and say, I could do it. Right. And so, you know, Paxos is very, very difficult to sort of explain intuitively. And then there was Zookeeper, which is an Apache project, which dealt with some of the,
每个人都报告他们的IP地址，然后选择最低的一个或类似的方法。但任何此类启发式方法都会导致某种灾难性的故障。比如想象一下某个子网宕机了，现在对每个人来说都变得非常混乱。所以很久以前有人想出了Paxos，这是一种机器之间在没有大量先验信息的情况下进行协商的方法。所以最终，你知道的，会有某种打破平局的机制。它可能就像处理器不完全执行相同的事情且它们不是确定性的这样一个事实一样简单。对吧。所以有一种打破平局的方法。但更重要的是，有一种达成共识的方法。所以一旦你有了某种打破平局的方法，当所有跟随者同时举手说“我能行”时，你能不能利用这种打破平局的机制最终选出一个单一的领导者？对吧。所以，你知道的，Paxos非常非常难以直观地解释。然后出现了Zookeeper，这是一个Apache项目，它处理了一些
like Paxos is an academic thing, but then in practice, just like anything in practice, there's real world challenges that you have to face. And so Zookeeper was a project that was built to do this leader election and all of that distributed consensus. But that also became extremely complicated. And as Yahoo and Google and these big companies were finding issues, they were patching them in. And then maybe they would fix a problem that meant these 17 other patches aren't needed anymore, but they wouldn't get cleaned out. And it just became very bloated. So someone wrote Raft. And I don't actually remember where Raft came from. But Raft is kind of a rewrite of distributed consensus. It's very clean, very elegant. And what I'm linking to here is a really nice explanation
类似于Paxos是一个学术概念，但在实践中，就像实践中的任何事情一样，你必须面对现实世界的挑战。因此，Zookeeper是一个旨在实现领导者选举和所有这些分布式共识的项目。但这也变得极其复杂。随着雅虎、谷歌和这些大公司发现问题，他们一直在打补丁。然后也许他们会修复一个问题，这意味着其他17个补丁不再需要了，但这些补丁并没有被清理掉。它变得非常臃肿。所以有人写了Raft。我其实不记得Raft是从哪里来的了。但Raft有点像对分布式共识的重新实现。它非常干净、非常优雅。我这里链接的是一个非常好的解释，
of Raft, you know, how it works and the principles behind it. And it has these cool infographics where it shows how, you know, okay, this leader dies and it represents everything with these little dots. So this dot went away and now these other dots, you know, need to pick a leader and it kind of goes through how all of that works. I think if you, when you start to think like you were kind of saying, it's actually a little bit mind blowing. Like when you think about if I have 10,000 computers, like trying to roughly mirror the state of each other and like decide what, what information is correct. And you start dealing with even the speed of light delays from one location to another data center you know halfway across the world and of course like it it isn't strictly just speed of light relative to the speed of a hard drive or whatever or ram
关于Raft的，你知道的，它是如何工作的以及背后的原理。它有一些很酷的信息图，展示了，你知道的，好吧，这个领导者死了，它用这些小圆点代表一切。所以这个圆点消失了，现在这些其他的圆点，你知道的，需要选出一个领导者，它会通篇讲解这一切是如何运作的。我觉得如果你开始思考，就像你刚才说的，这其实有点让人脑洞大开。比如当你考虑到如果我有1万台计算机，试图大致镜像彼此的状态，并决定什么信息是正确的。而且你还要处理从一个位置到地球另一端的数据中心的所谓光速延迟，当然，它并不仅仅严格受限于相对于硬盘或内存速度的光速，
and then start thinking like you were saying just like power outages or whatever it isn't neutrino strikes or whatever you always like getting a bit flipped and ran to like, when you increase your exposure like that, the problem is just so much more complicated. Yeah, it's totally mind blowing. And like, yeah, I mean, I mean, all these leader, all these followers, they're all, you know, the same, they're probably even running the same hardware, right? So they all just raise their hand at exactly the same time and say, Oh, we saw the leader died, you know, I'll be the next leader. And it's like, well, what do you do with that? It's a scale of 10,000,
然后开始思考，就像你刚才说的，只是停电或诸如此类的事情，或者中微子撞击之类的，你总是会遇到内存中发生比特翻转之类的情况，当你增加这种暴露度时，问题就会复杂得多。是的，这简直太让人大开眼界了。而且，是的，我的意思是，所有的这些领导者，所有的这些跟随者，它们全都是，你知道的，一样的，它们甚至可能运行相同的硬件，对吧？所以它们都会在完全同一时间举手说：“哦，我们看到领导者死了，你知道的，我来当下一个领导者。”这就好像，好吧，你拿这个怎么办？这是1万台机器的规模，
right? I mean, it's easy, dude. I mean, everyone always says the thing you're saying, like, pick the lowest, pick the lowest one. Well, pick the first person who raised their hand. It's like, well, how do you even define first like yeah like who is going to be the referee there if like once as soon as you have a referee who can define first then you've already solved the problem but like yeah you have to probably did it so yeah it's like now you have two problems you just have one god machine that sits somewhere in a like you know special housing that just you know guarantees to be up but what happens on sundays then yeah okay i mean mainframes people joke but like that that's like
对吧？我的意思是，这很简单，伙计。我的意思是，每个人总是说你刚才说的那种话，选最低的，选最低的一个。好吧，选第一个举手的人。这就好像，好吧，你甚至怎么定义“第一”？对吧？就像谁会是那里的裁判？如果一旦你有了能定义“第一”的裁判，那你其实就已经解决这个问题了。但这就好像，你可能已经这么做了，所以这就好比，现在你有两个问题了，你只是拥有了一个上帝机器，它坐在某个地方的特殊机箱里，（你知道的）只保证它一直开机，但那周日会发生什么呢？是的，好吧，我的意思是，人们开玩笑说大型机，但像银行和大型机之类的东西，部分原因就是为了绕过这个问题，他们称之为“大机”（Big Iron），对吧？它只是一台非常强大巨大的机器，里面的每个部件都有四重冗余，
banks and mainframes and stuff is in part like because of trying to get around this where they call like big iron right it's just like one really big powerful machine that you just four-way redundancy on every part inside and it it sounds like in some ways silly because things like google facebook whatever went to commodity hardware roughly but like there are cases if you're like transactions per second are low enough that maybe it just makes sense to have like one or two really really like a leader follower, you know, config. And the one machine just has an uptime that is like so guaranteed. And you restart it, like you said, maybe on Sundays when the bank is closed, like every Sunday during this hour, you restart the machine and the follower does the failover test. And then it goes down, you know, the next hour or whatever. And you have
在某些方面听起来可能有点傻，因为像谷歌、facebook之类的公司都转向了通用硬件，大致如此。但有些情况下，如果你的每秒事务处理量足够低，那么可能只需配置一台或两台真正非常强大的——类似于主从配置的机器，这就很有意义了。那台机器的正常运行时间得到了极大的保证。而且你重启它，就像你说的，也许在周日银行关门的时候，比如每周日在这个小时，你重启这台机器，跟随者进行故障转移测试。然后它就停机了，你知道的，在下一个小时左右。而且你还有
like a team of people dedicated to even those two machines alive. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, that's definitely a real thing. I think even today there's companies that run that way and there's, there's nothing wrong with that. I think given, as you said, if the QPS is low enough, it saves a lot of hassle, but yeah, the RAF thing is totally mind blowing. Definitely check it out. I'm, I've always been fascinated by it. I haven't had a reason to implement it myself, but, but it's always been a fascination. And it's very, it's also, as I said, with Patrick's article, it's like super fun to watch the animations. I do not have a good segue.
一队人专门负责维护这两台机器的存活。是的。是的。我的意思是，这绝对是真实存在的。我觉得即使在今天，也有按这种方式运营的公司，这没什么不对。我觉得鉴于你所说的，如果QPS（每秒查询率）足够低，这可以省去很多麻烦。不过，Raft这个东西真的让人脑洞大开。一定要去看看。我一直对它着迷。我虽然没有理由亲自去实现它，但它一直让我深深着迷。而且正如我所说，配合帕特克的文章，看动画真的超级有趣。我找不到很好的过渡，
So we're just hard cutting to my article, which is the mathematics of 2048. So there's more to the article title, but i don't want to spoil it yet so 2048 was a game that enjoyed i don't want to call it brief because someone will say like oh no i still play it's the best game ever but you have a a grid of oh man i don't even uh five by five i think it was it's sort of like five by five and then there are tiles that have a number on them so you start with like maybe the number one and the number one somewhere else in this five by five grid. And then you slide a direction to the right, up, down, or left.
所以我们直接切入我的文章，也就是《2048的数学原理》。文章标题其实更长剧透，但我现在还不想剧透。所以2048是一款曾经风靡的游戏，我不想叫它“短暂的”，因为会有人说：“哦，不，我还在玩，这是史上最好玩的游戏。”但你有一个网格——天哪，我甚至——大概是5乘5的吧，我觉得是5乘5的，然后上面有带有数字的方块。所以你开始时，在这个5乘5的网格中的某个地方有一个数字1，在另一个地方也有一个数字1。然后你朝一个方向滑动——向右、向上、向下或向左。
I mean, that's each of the four directions. And all of the tiles slide to the side of the grid that you swiped to. So like one tile is in the bottom left and one tile is in the upper right. And you swipe right, then that bottom left tile is going to slide to the right side, is in the bottom left and one tile is in the upper right and you swipe right then that bottom left tile is going to slide to the right side just like the other one and then if two tiles that are currently the same number crash into each other they merge and become double that number so if they have to be consecutive or how does that work no they have to be the same number so like if you have a one and a one and you crash them into each other
我的意思是，这就是那四个方向。所有的方块都会滑向你滑动的那一侧网格。比如一个方块在左下角，另一个方块在右上角，如果你向右滑动，那么那个左下角的方块就会滑向右侧——在左下角有一个方块，在右上角有一个方块，你向右滑动，那个左下角的方块就会滑向右侧，就像另一个方块一样——然后，如果两个当前数字相同的方块撞到一起，它们就会合并并变成该数字的两倍。所以，它们必须是连续的数字吗，还是怎么运作的？不是的，它们必须是相同的数字。所以，如果你有一个1和一个1，你把它们撞到一起，
they'll become a two but like what if there's another number in between the one yeah so then if there's like a two and a one and then a two and you slide down like stacked vertically and you slide down you'll just have two one two at the bottom of the screen got it so if you could somehow get the one to slide away then you could crash the two and two to each other got it i i probably butchered that but but you get i get it i get it okay and so there's of course like a bunch of descriptions of how you would um like how new tiles spawn so sometimes when you swipe new tiles will spawn on the screen and they spawn with like a given distribution and so like it's not always going to be it's most likely to be
它们就会变成2。但如果1和2之间还有另一个数字呢？哦，那如果在底部垂直堆叠着一个2、一个1和一个2，当你向下滑动时，你屏幕底部就会出现两个1和一个2。明白了。所以如果你能某种程度上让1滑开，那么你就可以让2和2撞到一起了。明白了。我可能解释得一塌糊涂，但我懂了，我懂了，好的。当然，会有很多关于新方块如何生成的描述。所以有时当你滑动时，屏幕上会生成新的方块，它们会按照给定的分布生成。所以它不总是——最可能是——
i don't remember like most likely to be a one a little less likely to be a two a little less likely to be a four and so numbers are going to spawn on and the idea is to keep collapsing down until you have a tile which is 2048 so 2048 is what 11 doublings from one and wait now jason's counting that sounds right so 256 is eight right then 512 is nine and 1024 is yeah you got it right man that was fast okay so 24 is 11 doublings right uh so you need to keep doubling and doubling but each doubling requires two inputs right so if you think about it if you only ever ones, you would need to eventually have like collapsed 2048 ones together. It's a lot, right? That's a lot of collapsing you would need to do.
我不记得了——最可能是1，稍微低一点可能是2，再低一点可能是4。所以数字会不断生成，而这里的核心思路就是不断向下折叠，直到你拥有一个值为2048的方块。所以2048是从1开始经过11次翻倍，等等，杰森现在正在数，听起来是对的。所以256是8次，对吧？然后512是9次，1024是——是的，你答对了，伙计，太快了。好的，所以2048是11次翻倍，对吧？——所以你需要不断翻倍、翻倍，但每次翻倍需要两个输入，对吧？所以如果你仔细想想，如果你只有1，你最终需要将2048个1折叠在一起。这很多，对吧？你需要进行大量的折叠。
But what ends up happening is like Jason was already asking about, if you have like a two and then one and a two stacked on top of each other, like you really want to collapse the twos, but maybe you don't because maybe actually you're going to collapse that one into a two and you want to collapse it into one of the other twos to make a four. So when and how you have to manage the board. So even if it's, you don't just always greedily take the highest number or the lowest number, like you need a bit of strategy because the more the board starts to fill up with this new tiles new tiles generating it becomes too crowded
但最终发生的情况是，就像杰森刚才问的，如果你有一个2，上面叠着一个1，上面又叠着一个2，你真的很想折叠那两个2，但也许你不能，因为实际上你打算把那个1折叠成一个2，然后你想把它和另一个2折叠在一起变成4。所以你什么时候以及如何管理棋盘。所以即使是这样，你也不能总是贪婪地选择最大或最小的数字，你需要一点策略，因为随着棋盘开始被这些新生成的方块填满，它会变得太拥挤，
and then eventually you lose right normally without getting to 2048 well i see so if the board gets full up and you can't collapse anything then you're done yes that's right got it then you lose and so of course not every game is is winnable i don't think or at least not with every decision and so uh you kind of don't know what's going to happen. So you play and you just kind of mindlessly swipe, right? So then the question is like, what's a good strategy? So, you know, when you're playing, so in a game like tic-tac-toe, right?
然后最终你会输掉，对吧？通常是在没有达到2048的情况下。哦，我明白了，如果棋盘满了，你什么也折叠不了，那你就玩完了？是的，没错。明白了，那你就输了。所以当然，不是每一局游戏都是能赢的，我觉得不是，或者至少不是每个决策都能赢。所以你有点不知道会发生什么。于是你玩的时候就会盲目地滑动，对吧？那么问题来了，什么是好策略呢？所以，你知道的，当你玩的时候，就像井字棋游戏一样，对吧？
Like the user, the other person can put in one of the nine spaces. So you can kind of like, I actually saw a t-shirt with it on like you can have a pictorial diagram of like the optimal tic-tac-toe strategy in like i don't know a very few states that you know each you only have x or o it's your turn then their turn they can only go in so many places the branching factor is really low you can actually represent the whole tree in like a very small amount of things which is like if you start in the upper left basically and then no matter where they play you can like predeterminately know the next state but then what about if you listen to people talking about like alpha go where the number of branching factors are like high
就像用户，另一个人可以在这9个空格之一中落子。所以你可以——我其实见过一件印有这个图案的T恤——你可以画一张直观的图表，展示最优的井字棋策略，只需要很少的状态，你知道，每个人只有X或O，轮到你，然后轮到他们，他们只能走那么多地方，分支因子非常低，你实际上可以用极少量的状态来表示整棵树。就像如果你基本上从左上角开始，然后无论他们怎么下，你都可以预先确定下一步的状态。但是，如果你听人们谈论像AlphaGo这样的东西，其中分支因子的数量非常大，
number of states is gigantically big there's a whole you know another class of problems so for this 2048 article the reason why i have it here is not for building general game AIs, but it's talking about something which I was hearing a lot about as you start hearing about machine learning, artificial intelligence, depending on your feeling about that, but is hidden Markov models and Markov decision processes, which is, I'm going to butcher this. Jason's going to tell me I'm wrong. But my takeaway from reading this article, which the reason I bothered to read it was because I
状态的数量大得惊人，这就属于另一类问题了。所以对于这篇2048的文章，我把它放在这里的目的不是为了构建通用的游戏AI，而是因为它谈论了某些我开始听到很多的东西——当你开始接触机器学习、人工智能时，取决于你对它的感觉——也就是隐马尔可夫模型和马尔可夫决策过程。我要把这个概念讲得一塌糊涂了。杰森会告诉我我错了。但我阅读这篇文章的收获——我之所以费劲去读它，是因为我
keep hearing about these MDPs, MDPs, you know, trying to figure out what you're going to do in this modeling is that for this game, as I described, first of all, there's this random part, right? It isn't like you battling another person. The game is just randomly generating what happens next.
不断听到关于这些MDP、MDP的事情，试图弄清楚你在这种建模中要做什么——对于这个游戏，正如我所描述的，首先，这里有一个随机部分，对吧？这不像是你在跟另一个人对战。游戏只是随机生成接下来的情况。
It's like Sudoku, right? Oh, no, but it's not because when you swipe things... I've never played this game, so I'm just trying to piece it together. When you swipe things, there's empty space there. What happens? Like more numbers go in that space? Yes. So the game will roll some dice and decide, you know, generate a random number and decide
这就像数独，对吧？哦，不，但它不是，因为当你滑动东西时……我从没玩过这个游戏，所以我只是在拼凑理解。当你滑动东西时，那里有空白区域。会发生什么？更多的数字会进入那个空间吗？是的。所以游戏会掷一些骰子，决定生成一个随机数字，并决定
where and what number to place there with some probability okay yeah so you control your action but you don't control the other person's action it's not like the game is trying to beat you right it's just randomly happening so you can't even apply really game theory and that like the opponent is like i can know what they're going to do because strategically they're going to do this so each state you have a choice you can swipe left right up or down and depending on what the game is going to do will determine if that was a good or bad thing but that doesn't mean you just pick randomly you can know that hey i swipe up the game state is this the distribution is that the probability that that's a good move is, you know, point two, best move. And this other
以某种概率在何处放置什么数字。哦，好吧。所以你控制你的行动，但你不控制对方的行动。这不像是游戏在试图打败你，它只是随机发生的。所以你甚至不能真正应用博弈论，认为对手会怎么做，因为从战略上讲他们会这样做。所以在每种状态下你都有一个选择，你可以向左、向右、向上或向下滑动，根据游戏的下一步走向来决定这是一个好还是坏的选择。但这并不意味着你只是随机挑选。你可以知道，嘿，我向上滑动，游戏状态是这样的，概率分布是那样的，这是一个好走法的概率是，你知道的，0.2，这是最佳走法。而另一个
move is point four, best move. And the way you might try to do that is by basically marching the states forward, figuring out like if you're in a winning or losing state, and then propagating it, you know, back to your state. So roughly, I'm giving you a high level vision of without going in a full explanation of Markov decision processes, because I'm no expert. But sometimes you'll end up in a state where you'll lose. And there may be a choice where no matter what you do, there's some probability of losing. But maybe you pick the one that minimizes that probability, right? And maybe there's a really good state you want the computer to give you. And so you want to try to increase the likelihood that you'll get an improvement. So he starts with, or she, I don't know, the article writer starts with a two by two grid, and I think getting to 64.
走法的概率是0.4，这是最佳走法。你尝试这样做的方法基本上是通过向前推进状态，弄清楚你处于赢棋还是输棋状态，然后将结果（你知道的）反向传播到你的当前状态。所以大体上，我在没有对马尔可夫决策过程做出完整解释的情况下，给你提供了一个高层视角，因为我不是专家。但有时你会陷入一种必输的状态。而且可能会有一种选择，无论你做什么，都存在某种失败的概率。但也许你选择那个能将该概率降到最低的选择，对吧？也许有一个非常好的状态是你希望计算机带你去的。所以你想努力增加获得改进的可能性。所以文章的作者——或者她，我不知道，文章作者从一个2乘2的网格开始，我想目标是达到64。
And then running this mark, this Markov decision process as a way of showing how this would happen in a in a sort of much more bounded problem set where you can sort of reason about this, and then talk about how you would extrapolate it to the full game into playing to 2048, where you may not be able to hold all possible game states in your memory at one time because it becomes too high. And how would you apply heuristics? How would this Markov decision process work? And just a really good introduction. So if you, in your ramblings about the internet, have come across Markov decision processes, which is related in a way that I'm entitled to speak about
然后运行这个马尔可夫决策过程，以此来展示这如何在这样一个范围小得多的问题集中发生——在其中你可以对这个问题进行推理，然后讨论如何将其外推到完整的游戏中，去玩到2048。在完整的游戏中，你可能无法同时将所有可能的游戏状态保存在内存中，因为状态空间变得太大了。以及你将如何应用启发式方法？这个马尔可夫决策过程将如何运作？这真的是一篇很好的入门文章。所以如果你在互联网的闲逛中遇到过马尔可夫决策过程——它与我有资格谈论的隐马尔可夫模型有着某种相关性，
hidden Markov models themselves, then this may be an article that is pretty interesting to you. Cool. Yeah. I mean, you did a really good job. So just like people don't know, that was my whole PhD was on MDPs and POMDPs and everything. And yeah, the article is super, super interesting. Definitely check it out. If you've played 2048, it's really cool to see something that you've played, you know, connect this tech to something that you've played.
那么这篇文章对你来说可能会非常有趣。太棒了。是的。我的意思是，你做得真的很棒。所以为了让大家知道，我的整个博士学位研究的就是MDP、POMDP（部分可观察马尔可夫决策过程）以及所有这些。是的，这篇文章非常非常有趣。一定要去看看。如果你玩过2048，看到你玩过的内容，把这种技术和你玩过的游戏联系起来，真的超级酷。
It really like makes it real. But yeah, I think you nailed it. I think it's, you know, you could say that like, maybe it's a partially observable MDP because you don't know what's coming next. But you can model it with an MDP. And as you said, it just means that sometimes you'll lose anyways just because you're unlucky
它真的让这一切变得真实了。不过是的，我觉得你抓住了精髓。我觉得，你知道的，你可以说，也许这是一个部分可观察的MDP（POMDP），因为你不知道接下来会发生什么。但你可以用MDP来对它进行建模。正如你所说，这意味着有时无论如何你都会输，仅仅是因为你运气不好，
and that's okay. And you just kind of model that into the system. Okay. Well, I'm glad that you reaffirming that I got a takeaway actually makes me pretty happy because that means that maybe I'm advancing. You never know, right? When it's a topic you don't understand, you read a thing and you're like, oh, I kind of get it. We don't know if you're right or wrong.
而这没关系。你只要把这一点建模到系统中就行了。好的，很高兴你确认了我的理解是对的，这其实让我挺开心的，因为这意味着也许我正在进步。你永远说不准，对吧？当这是一个你不了解的主题时，你读了一篇文章，然后觉得：“哦，我大概懂了。”但你不知道自己是对是错。
Yeah, I know. I think you nailed it, man. Yeah, I've always had a big fascination with puzzles and games and the way that they're solved. And so this kind of stuff definitely scratches that itch. Definitely check out this article. It's really solid. I think it's time for our book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show is a podcast. I'm totally cheating, but I've been binging on this podcast. It's called manager tools podcast. You know, originally I, I found it through a literal search. I actually, I literally wanted I literally wanted tools to make me a better manager.
是的，我懂，我觉得你抓住了精髓，伙计。是的，我一直对谜题、游戏以及它们的解法有着巨大的迷恋。所以这种东西绝对能满足我的好奇心。一定要去看看这篇文章。真的很扎实。我想是时候介绍我们的本期好书了。本期好书。我本期推荐的好书是一个播客。我完全是在作弊，但我一直在疯狂追听这个播客。它叫《经理人工具播客》（Manager Tools podcast）。你知道，最初我通过字面搜索找到了它。我实际上——我字面意思上想要
But what I found instead was their interpretation of tools, they really mean techniques or skills or advice. And so while I didn't get any literal tools out of this podcast that I could use to make me more efficient, I'm learning a ton of information. And I would recommend this to anybody. I mean, not just managers, like anyone who is working in a job or plans to have any job at all should check out this podcast. You know, I have a lot of these situations or things that I've had in the past. And, you know, some of these are lessons I learned the hard way and they kind of explain it in so much, you know, better detail and candor. Some of these things are things that
我字面意思上想要能让我成为更好经理的工具。但相反我发现的是，他们对“工具”的解释，实际上指的是技巧、技能或建议。所以虽然我没有从这个播客中获得任何能让我提高效率的字面意义上的工具，但我学到了大量的知识。我向所有人推荐这个。我的意思是，不仅是经理，任何有工作或打算找工作的人都应该听听这个播客。你知道，我遇到了很多这样的情况，或者经历过过去发生的事情。而且，你知道的，其中有些是我通过艰难方式吸取到的教训，他们以更加详尽和坦诚的细节解释了这些。其中有些事情是
I was doing that I think I'm going to change. Some of the things they talk about are reaffirming things that I felt like were good ideas. But in general, it talks all about, you know, kind of being a leader. And I think they do a lot of talk about project planning, which is our topic today. So it's also a good reference there. And I was listening to an episode today. And one thing that really, you know, was funny was they were talking about sort of how do you delegate so imagine you have a giant project that you're leading and you need help with that project right you could be a manager and you're given a project with large scope you could be a
我过去一直在做，而我认为我将要改变它们。他们讨论的一些事情重申了我认为是不错的主意。但总的来说，它讨论的全都是，你知道的，如何成为一个领导者。而且我觉得他们谈了很多关于项目规划的内容，这也是我们今天的话题。所以这也是一个很好的参考。我今天在听一期节目，有一件真的（你知道的）很有趣的事是，他们在讨论如何授权——所以想象一下，你正在领导一个巨大的项目，你需要该项目的帮助，对吧？你可能是一个经理，你被赋予了一个范围很大的项目；你可能是一个
an engineer you could be just a high school or a college student and you have some team project that you're working on where you're trying to get help with other people. And it talks about, you know, how do you sort of share that responsibility? One of the funny things is they said that one of the people that they talked to said, oh, I wish I was CEO because then I wouldn't have any direct responsibility. And I think the idea there was like, if you're the CEO, you just tell people what to do. And then when you tell them what to do, now it's their responsibility. And, you know, I mean, most people, I think, could see where that's going. But just to like make it explicit, that doesn't work that way. When you ask someone for help, what you're doing is you're just doubling the responsibility. Now you're responsible and
工程师；你可能只是一个高中生或大学生，你正在做一个团队项目，正试图从其他人那里获得帮助。它讨论的是，你知道的，你如何分享这种责任？其中一件有趣的事是，他们说他们采访过的一个人说：“哦，我希望我是首席执行官，因为那样我就没有任何直接责任了。”我想那里的想法是，如果你是首席执行官，你只要告诉别人该做什么就行了。然后当你告诉他们该做什么时，现在这就是他们的责任了。而且，你知道的，我的意思是，大多数人，我想，都能看出这会走向何方。但为了把它明确说出来，事情并不是这样的。当你向某人寻求帮助时，你所做的只是把责任翻倍了。现在你负有责任，
that person's responsible, but it's necessary because you can't do everything by yourself. But you're not actually reducing any responsibility by becoming a leader. It doesn't work that way. That was a really funny thing that came up in today's episode of their show, but, but definitely check it out. I've been having a blast listening to it. The people have good candor. They're ex military people.
那个人也负有责任，但这是必须的，因为你不可能一个人做所有事情。但你并没有通过成为领导者来减轻任何责任。事情不是这样的。这是今天他们的节目中出现的一个非常有趣的事情，但——一定要去听听。我听得津津有味。这些人很坦诚。他们是前军人，
And so they, they speak like ex military people. And so I kind of enjoy it. It's kind of gruff and like straight to the point and stuff, which is that, that is I think kind of good for easy for me to listen to, but give it a give it a listen i've been binging on it i've been really enjoying it my book of the show is also not a book but it is print so i guess it counts it's make magazine you know i i'm i'm pretty sure that i probably had this like as a reference or
所以他们说话就像前军人那样。所以我挺喜欢的。它有点粗犷，直奔主题之类的，这对我来说——我觉得听起来挺容易接受的。去听听吧，我一直在疯狂追听，非常享受。我本期推荐的好书也不是一本书，但它是印刷品，所以我想它也算数。它是《Make》杂志。你知道的，我——我非常确凿地认为我以前可能把这个当作参考资料，
something on here before but i mean people probably had this like as a reference or something on here before. But I mean, people probably at this point have heard or seen Make Magazine. Yeah, it used to be like at Barnes & Noble and stuff. It might still be, right? I think it still is. I mean, if you ever go to those stores. Yeah, if Barnes & Noble even exists. I mean, I don't know.
或者在这里提过。但我意思是，大家在这个阶段可能都听说过或见过《Make》杂志。是的，它以前在巴诺书店（Barnes & Noble）之类的书店里卖。现在可能还在，对吧？我想现在还在。我的意思是，如果你去过那些店的话。是的，如果巴诺书店还存在的话。我的意思是，我不知道。
It goes through ebbs and flow of like, I guess, popularity. You know, there was like the really big boom of like cosplaying and hobby stuff like when the internet was so in sympathy and like instructables was really huge i remember yeah i remember that yeah i mean it probably still is around i mean i know it is around i think it got bought by a company anyways you know this thing has become went from like the first making it big to like actually even though it was a niche magazine it became too generic and more niche magazines that were you know like hobbyist electronics hobbyist cosplay making hobbyist cnc like all those things became their own topics with enough you know ability for people to look
它经历过流行程度的高潮和低谷。你知道的，当时有一波非常大的Cosplay（角色扮演）和爱好者的热潮，就在互联网刚兴起、Instructables网站非常火的时候，我记得，是的，我记得那个。是的，我的意思是，它现在可能还在。我的意思是，我知道它还在，我想它后来被一家公司收购了。无论如何，你知道的，这个东西从最早的大火，变得——尽管它是一本小众杂志，但它变得有点太大众化了，然后更多更小众的杂志出现了，你知道的，比如电子爱好者、Cosplay制作爱好者、CNC（数控）爱好者——所有这些都变成了它们自己的独立主题，拥有足够的人气让人们去了解
into them that you know maybe it sort of robbed some of the like make magazines you know yeah kind of shine but i always thought that you know although there, kind of shine. But I always thought that, you know, although there's been very few projects I've ever done out of make magazine, always appreciate that, like, they go through document describe and have a way of kind of covering a wide variety of things from like crazy dangerous, like Tesla coil making to like, know hey here's a air pressure uh you know soda bottle rocket you can make in your backyard and you know i just i still subscribe to it i even keep the magazines because i feel like having it in hard copy it was just cool oh you have the physical magazines like recent ones oh yeah yeah yeah yeah oh i would show people but we're only
它们，这可能在某种程度上剥夺了《Make》杂志的（你知道的）那种光芒。但我一直认为，你知道的，尽管我在《Make》杂志上做过的项目寥寥无几，但我一直很感激，像他们那样，通过文档记录、描述，并以一种涵盖广泛事物的方式——从疯狂危险的特斯拉线圈制作，到像“嘿，这是一个你可以在后院制作的气压汽水瓶火箭”这样的项目。而且，你知道的，我依然订阅它，我甚至保留着这些杂志，因为我觉得拥有纸质实体版真的很酷。哦，你有实体杂志？最近的那些？哦，真的，真的，真的，真的。哦，我会给别人看，但我们只是
audio right behind me. I'm looking right now and I'm seeing thousands. I'm just kidding. I don't know that I've kept everyone, but I keep them always like, oh, there's something in here I want to make or reference or look at. This is good. I don't know. Maybe I'm an old person now, but it's nostalgic.
音频节目。就在我身后。我现在看着，我看到了成千上万本。我开玩笑的。我不知道我是不是留下了每一本，但只要有我想制作、参考或查看的内容，我就会把它们留着。这挺好的。我不知道。也许我现在是个老人了，但这很怀旧。
No, I think it's kind of like the NAS, right? It's satisfying to just have it. Yeah, exactly. And just physically thumbing through it when you're on an airplane or whatever, where it's satisfying to just have it yeah exactly and you know just physically thumbing through it you know when you're on an airplane or whatever where it's still like electronics is a bit of a chore although that's even becoming less and less i kind of used to look forward to going in an airplane and not being allowed to use electronics i catch up on reading but now like that's not even a thing well not going on airplanes but also airplanes that allow your
不，我觉得这有点像NAS，对吧？仅仅是拥有它就让人感到满足。是的， exactement。而且当你在飞机上或什么地方时，亲手翻阅它——仅仅是拥有它就让人感到满足，是的， exactement。而且你知道，仅仅是亲手翻阅它，当你坐在飞机上或其它地方时，虽然电子设备的使用已经不那么麻烦了，尽管这也在逐渐减少。我以前有点期待上飞机时不被允许使用电子设备，这样我就可以赶着读读书，但现在——那甚至都不是个事了。好吧，不仅是不坐飞机，还有飞机允许你使用电子设备，并且拥有——是的，这是真的，你知道的。
electronics and having like yeah that's true you know what. Well, not going on airplanes, but also airplanes that allow your electronics and having one. Yeah, that's true. You know, what I've done now is I've put my phone in. Even when the airplane has internet, I still put my phone in airplane mode, you know, without the Wi-Fi. And that way it's like I'm at least unplugged and I won't be able to use the internet. But also the thing I'll recommend is like, you know, of course, they have a blog, lots of articles. I appreciate what they do.
好吧，不仅是不坐飞机，还有飞机允许你使用电子设备，并且拥有——是的，这是真的，你知道的，我现在做的是，我把手机放进——即使飞机上有网络，我仍然会把手机调成飞行模式（你知道的，不连Wi-Fi）。这样至少我是“下线”状态，也没法上网。不过我推荐的另一件事是，你知道的，他们当然有一个博客，有很多文章。我很欣赏他们做的事情。
They used to have, which I think have also sort of tapered down or even, you know, gone away to some extent, especially now with COVID. But they used to have maker fairs where, you know, people would come and just celebrate me. That was always really cool. Have you ever gone to that?
他们以前有——我想现在也有些缩减，甚至在某种程度上消失了，尤其是现在有了新冠疫情。但他们以前有“创客展”（Maker Faire），在那里人们会来庆祝“创客”文化。那总是非常酷。你以前去过吗？
Yeah, I have. Yeah, yeah. I went to the one in the Bay Area and it was probably three years ago. It was super fun. I always wanted to go back and then I wasn't able to go the Bay Area. And that was probably three years ago. It was super fun. I always wanted to go back. And then I wasn't able to go the next year. And I think it rained.
我去过。是的，我去过湾区的那个，大概是三年前吧。真的超级有趣。我一直想再去，但后来没能去成湾区。那是大概三年前的事了。真的超级有趣。我一直想再去。然后第二年我去不了了。我想那天下雨了。
And then the next year was COVID or whatever. So yeah, I don't think that happened. And then I think they've gone through some sort of restructuring. I didn't follow it exactly. The other thing I'll say is, you know, if you have other people who are peripherally interested, it may be very hard to spam them a link or convince them to go to a website or watch a YouTube video, or if you have children, right, or whatever, like having the magazine around and someone picking it up and just looking at it. And
然后第二年就是新冠疫情之类的。所以，是的，我觉得那次没办成。再后来，他们经历了一些重组。我没有密切关注。我要说的另一件事是，你知道的，如果你身边有其他人只是边缘性地感兴趣，向他们发送链接、说服他们访问网站、观看YouTube视频可能会很难，或者如果你有孩子，对吧，或者是别的什么，把杂志放在周围，让某人顺手拿起来翻阅，
like, you know, the sort of lower commitment of that and then becoming intrigued. You know, my kids call it the robot magazine, like, Oh, look at the robot magazine. Yeah, look at it. And I think, you know, just having that stuff laying around where you can sort of bump across it as opposed to your, you know, normal kind of filter bubble for maybe other people, even if you yourself, you know, could find it and look for it. Uh, there's some value to that anyways, but I, I appreciate what, you know, make magazine sort of has done in the influence it's had. Very cool, man. I, I kind of on a related note, I actually learned to solder. So I've soldered. Yeah, I've soldered things before. But usually
（你知道的）这种较低的投入，然后他们就会被吸引住。你知道，我的孩子们把它叫作“机器人杂志”，比如：“哦，看那个机器人杂志。”是的，看看它。我觉得，把这些东西放在周围，让你能够偶然碰到它，而不是像你平时那样只呆在自己的“过滤泡”里去看那些你甚至自己就能找到和搜索的东西，这还是有一定价值的。无论如何，我很感激《Make》杂志所做的事情以及它产生的影响。太酷了，伙计。顺便说一句，我其实学会了焊接。所以我有过焊接经验。但通常
soldering to me was like I would just turn the temperature of the soldering iron way too hot. This is the other thing. I bought the soldering iron from Ali Express. And it does it didn't tell me Celsius versus Fahrenheit and I just assumed Fahrenheit being an American it was actually Celsius I was like man it's like so freaking hot and so so that was a big problem but then also I would basically just end up with this huge glob of was it flux I guess no solder or solder okay i don't know but just just and i've never had to solder something on a pcb before so i've never had to be that precise anyways it was usually just repairing like you know like my son pulled a plug out of the wall too hard or something so
对我来说焊接就像是——我会把电烙铁的温度调得太高。这是另一回事。我从全球速卖通（AliExpress）买的电烙铁。它上面没有告诉我到底是摄氏度还是华氏度，作为一个美国人，我理所当然地以为是华氏度，结果其实是摄氏度。我当时想：“天哪，这也太烫了吧！”所以——这真是个大问题。但除此之外，我基本上最后都会弄出一大团——是助焊剂吗？我想不是，是焊锡吧？焊锡，好吧，我不知道，反正就是一大团。而且我以前从来没有在PCB（印刷电路板）上焊接过东西，所以从来没有需要那么精准过。总之，通常只是修理一些东西，比如我儿子用力过猛把插头从墙上拔下来了之类的。
like you didn't have to but i know but just this huge glob of metal like and you just be this giant like uh state puff marshmallow metal man just hanging off the end of everything and that was my way of fixing things but i i bought a a tiny speaker which i'm using for an arduino prod for arduino halloween project which which we did and um as someone who doesn't know how to solder i was like well i'll get the one where i can screw you know yeah like it has like a screw when you screw it puts two plates together and squeezes the wire terminal, screw terminal. There you go. Um, but the screw, the, the wire, the speaker was smaller than I expected and the wire was smaller than I expected and it wouldn't stay in the screw terminal. And I flipped the PCB over and there was like
就像你本来不用这样做，但我懂，就是这一大团金属，然后你就会变成一个巨大的、像棉花糖一样的金属人，挂在所有东西的末端，这曾是我解决问题的方法。不过我买了一个小喇叭，我把它用在一个Arduino项目上，一个我们做过的Arduino万圣节项目。作为一个不会焊接的人，我在想，好吧，我要找那种可以用螺丝固定的，对吧，就像它有一个螺丝，当你拧紧时，它会把两块板压在一起，夹住电线。螺丝接线端子，就是这样。但是那个螺丝，那个，电线，喇叭比我预期的要小，电线也比我预期的要小，而且它在螺丝端子里呆不住。我把PCB板翻过来，那里有
contact points there that you could solder to. And I was like, okay, I rolled up my sleeves. Like I'm going to learn how to solder for real, a real like a like a professional solder oh professional solder okay yeah well i'm gonna try i'm gonna i'm gonna at least get to the amateur level and so uh you know it just took me a lot of practice and um and yeah i got it to where like i had this really nice shape and it was like also holding the speaker wire uh you know pretty well so i mean i will warn you like i assume the speaker wire was probably stranded and not solid and soldering stranded wire is much harder than solid wire and soldering wire in general is harder than soldering like actual components like resistors diodes you know
你可以焊接的接触点。当时我想，好吧，我卷起袖子。我要真正学会焊接，像个真正的、专业的焊工一样——哦，专业的焊工，好吧，好吧，我要试一试，我至少要达到业余水平。所以，你知道，这花了我很多练习，然后，是的，我做到了，我的焊点形状非常好，而且也（把喇叭线）固定得相当好。我是说，我要提醒你一下，我猜那根喇叭线可能是多股绞合线，而不是单股实心线，焊接绞合线比焊接实心线难得多，而且总的来说，焊接电线比焊接实际的元件，比如电阻、二极管，也就是
through components so yeah you didn't take on the easiest thing for sure yeah i mean it was just thrust on me right but yeah i mean i also yeah i was worried that one of the strands would you know cross over and short circuit um but that hasn't happened yet so uh i was so satisfied i did all that work and then um i started the arduino up and uh it was uh probably even an instructables site but it was a project where it would play like the mac boot up sound like that you know and it worked and like it came out of the speaker and i was like oh it felt so satisfying it was unbelievably satisfying to do that and then i looked around at like all the
直插式元件要难得多。所以，是的，你接手的可不是最简单的活。对，我是说，这纯粹是强加给我的，对吧？不过是的，我也担心其中一根细丝会，你知道，搭接在一起造成短路，但目前还没发生过。所以我太满足了，我做了所有这些工作，然后，我启动了Arduino，这可能甚至是一个Instructables网站上的项目，它会播放像Mac开机声音那样的声音，你知道的。它成功了，声音从喇叭里传出来，当时我就想，哦，感觉太棒了，做到这一步简直有一种不可思议的满足感。然后我环顾四周，看着所有
other really terrible soldering jobs and i'm like like, one day I'm going to, I'm going to fix these. Yeah. It does wait till you learn about doing surface mount soldering with like 0.1 millimeter pitch, like pieces of pins between things. And so those people get crazy. Oh man, I can't even imagine. But then of course they also use like ovens to basically melt the solder and the pieces together in one go oh okay yeah yeah one thing i realized is i'll need some kind of i think they call it helping hands but it's like these hands with a magnifying glass alligator clips on them yeah yeah right yeah
其他非常糟糕的焊接工作，心想，总有一天我要，我要把这些都修好。是啊，等你以后了解到表面贴装焊接，比如间隙只有0.1毫米的引脚时，你就知道了。那些人简直疯狂。天哪，我简直无法想象。但当然，他们也会用烤箱之类的设备，基本上是一次性把焊锡和零件熔化在一起。哦，好吧，好吧。我意识到的一件事是，我需要某种东西，我想他们叫它第三只手（helping hands），就是那种带有放大镜和鳄鱼夹的手。对，对，就是那个。
also the trick with the wire while we're at it and then we can move on is get smiths is they call it pre-tinting the wire so if you twist the strands together right like just twist them just like one wires strands like all together so and then take your soldering gun and just apply solder only to the wire and then cut it to the length you want and then what happens is you have basically already solder on the wire solder on the pad so you just have to touch them together and briefly touch the iron the soldering iron to both of them and then the solder will flow together and the solder more readily flows to itself than it flows to either of the other metals and so you basically reduce the like time you have to spend
另外，顺便说一下电线的技巧，然后我们就可以继续了，就是所谓的“预上锡”（pre-tinning）电线。所以，如果你把绞合线的各股拧在一起，对吧——就像把一根电线的各股拧在一起——然后拿起你的电烙铁，只把焊锡涂在电线上，接着把它剪到你想要的长度。这样一来，基本上你的电线上已经有焊锡了，焊盘上也有焊锡，所以你只需要把它们触碰在一起，用电烙铁短暂地同时接触它们两端，焊锡就会融合在一起。焊锡流向自身的倾向比流向任何一种其他金属的倾向更强，所以你基本上减少了
uh sort of trying to get that to work oh interesting very cool all right well in the time we'll we'll go a little quicker here we've had so many cool things to talk about but we'll we'll want to give time to the to the to the task at hand so my tool this show is workflowy this is very simple it's a recursive google doc so you know you can write a google doc or you can write a workflow you write a document and at some point in a document if you're doing something that involves planning or something, at some point, you're going to have a bulleted list. Like it's inevitable, right?
试图让它工作所花费的时间。哦，很有趣，非常酷。好了，在接下来的时间里，我们会过得快一点，我们有太多酷炫的话题要聊，但我们还是想留出时间来处理当务之急。所以，我在这期节目里的工具是Workflowy。这是一个非常简单的工具，它是一个递归的谷歌文档（Google Doc）。你知道，你可以写一个谷歌文档，或者你可以写一个Workflowy。你写下一份文档，在文档的某个地方，如果你在做一些涉及规划或类似的事情，在某个时刻，你会列出一个项目符号列表（bulleted list）。就像这是不可避免的，对吧？
It's like things to do or what have you. Anytime you create a bulleted list in Workflowy, you know, you can have a nested list and you can actually collapse the list. And then if you tap on one of the bullets, it actually opens that bulleted list as like its own sub document. And so that way you don't have this enormous, massive bulleted list.
比如“待办事项”或诸如此类的内容。每当你在Workflowy中创建一个项目符号列表时，你知道的，你可以有一个嵌套列表，而且你实际上可以折叠这个列表。然后，如果你点击其中一个项目符号，它实际上会把那个项目符号列表当作它自己的子文档打开。这样一来，你就不会有一个庞大无比的项目符号列表。
It's like with all the levels, like instead you have, you know, maybe five bullets, they're all collapsed. And when you tap one, it takes you straight to that, you know, it unfolds that in a new document. So the high level thing here is Workflowy. It's on desktop. It's on mobile. So it's on all the important platforms.
就像包含所有层级一样，取而代之的是，你可能有，你知道的，大约五个项目符号，它们全都是折叠的。当你点击其中一个时，它会直接把你带到那个位置，你知道的，在新的文档中展开它。所以这里的高层级概念就是Workflowy。它有桌面版。它有移动版。所以它支持所有重要的平台。
And I found it really, really useful in keeping track of stuff. I think even for project planning, I found Workflowy to be super useful. So I've used it for many, many different things. I highly recommend it. Nice. Is it on your I highly recommend it. Nice. Is it on your NAS?
我发现它在追踪各种事情方面真的非常非常有用。我想即使对于项目规划，我也发现Workflowy超级有用。所以我把它用在了很多不同的事情上。我强烈推荐它。太棒了。它在你的——我强烈推荐它。太棒了。它在你的NAS上吗？
Tie it all together. Mine is GitHub Desktop. I don't always use GitHub or Git. Well, I should say I do use Git for our workflow at work, but I am not very good at it. I often find myself Googling, how do you do this thing again? Yep.
把这一切串联起来。我的是GitHub Desktop（GitHub桌面客户端）。我并不总是使用GitHub或Git。嗯，我应该说，我在工作中的工作流确实会使用Git，但我并不是很擅长。我经常发现自己在用谷歌搜索：“这个东西到底怎么操作来着？”是的。
GitHub Desktop, which if you uh have uh specifically if you're using a github at all or even if you're just i think it works even if you're just doing it locally the nice thing is that it's a a gui for the get to workflows so it allows you to visually see some of the things especially for me helpful if you get into more complex circumstances or rebasing and yeah some things like not going quite right i don't normally need it if i'm just doing you know git commit dash a dash m check in you know i don't need you know github desktop to do that for me but visualizing if i have a whole if i'm doing a refactor or a whole bunch of files are open
GitHub Desktop，如果你——特别是如果你根本就在使用GitHub，或者甚至我想如果你只是在本地使用它，它的好处在于它是Git工作流的一个图形用户界面（GUI）。所以它允许你直观地看到一些东西，尤其对我很有帮助，如果你遇到更复杂的情况，比如变基（rebasing），或者有些事情没有完全按预期进行的话。如果我只是在做日常的，你知道的，git commit dash a dash m 检查（check in），你知道的，我通常不需要它，我不需要GitHub Desktop来帮我做那个。但是，如果我要进行重构，或者有一大堆文件处于打开状态，想要可视化地查看某些东西，对吧？
or I'm wanting to see something, right? I think it actually has been really nice and I'm appreciative that they, you know, kind of took time to make that. So why is it GitHub? GitHub desktop is what it's called. But is it called GitHub because they made it or? Yes.
或者我想直观地看到某些东西，对吧？我觉得它其实非常棒，我很感激他们花时间把这个工具做出来。所以它为什么叫GitHub？GitHub Desktop是它的名字。但它叫GitHub是因为他们制作了它吗？是的。
Oh, okay, got it. So it's for any Git, it's just made by github you know i'm gonna assume it is but i actually don't know but yeah i mean if a lot of people for hobby projects are using of course like open public github repositories and so uh you know i still think it has use even for there um but yeah, being able to visualize this, if you have a GitHub workflow, and I think it's super valuable for a lot of those more complex things that really help by being visual. Yeah, I think it has extra features
哦，好吧，明白了。所以它适用于任何Git仓库，只是由GitHub制作的。你知道，我猜是这样的，但我其实并不确定。不过，是的，如果很多人在做业余项目时，当然都在使用开放的公共GitHub仓库，所以，你知道的，我仍然认为它甚至在那里也很有用。但话说回来，能够直观地看到这些，如果你有一个GitHub工作流，我认为对于许多那些通过可视化会变得非常有帮助的更复杂的事情来说，它是超级有价值的。是的，我觉得它有额外的功能，
if you're using a GitHub Git repo, but it works for regular Git as well. I also learned about some really powerful Git tooling, and then it required me to first learn Emacs. And so I failed, and this is my alternative. Oh, man. Poor Emacs. I used to use Emacs every single day, all the time. And now it's like Visual Studio Code just really is just so nice.
如果你使用的是GitHub的Git仓库的话，但它也适用于普通的Git。我还了解了一些非常强大的Git工具，但前提是我必须先学会Emacs。结果我失败了，而这就是我的替代方案。天哪，可怜的Emacs。我以前每天都在使用Emacs，一直都在用。现在感觉Visual Studio Code真的是太好用了。
It's very hard to match that to convenience and the integration with the OS is just a lot nicer, which is a shame, shame for Emacs. All right, well, I think it's time to plan our projects. That's right, project planning. So what are different types of tropes like there's a lot of these like waterfall and agile and yeah i when we were preparing for the show jason and we're talking about this which is a whole other subtopic first of all you know this is by no means expert
要匹配那种便利性以及与操作系统的集成度真的很困难，好用太多了，这对于Emacs来说真是一个遗憾，对Emacs真是一个遗憾。好了，我想是时候规划我们的项目了。没错，项目规划。那么，都有哪些不同类型的套路（tropes）呢？比如有很多这种瀑布流（waterfall）和敏捷开发（agile），是的。当我们为节目做准备时，杰森，我们谈到了这个，这完全是另一个子话题。首先，你知道的，这绝非专家的见解，
and we're actually going to talk about these briefly and then not talk about them again and talk about more practical uh thoughtful, common ways of planning projects. But there are rigorous approaches to this process. And in fact, if you are, which I suspect most people are, of a software engineer inclination or not a product or project manager who regularly interacts with this, you will probably be more at home with what we're going to talk about. If your profession is managing projects, you will probably find this appalling. So I apologize. But, you know, the traditional way people kind of build software is, I guess you would call it waterfall. You do step one, you get it kind of done, you get your thing, then that flows into step two,
而且我们实际上会简单地讨论一下这些，然后不再多谈，转而讨论更实用、更周到、更常见的项目规划方法。不过，这个过程确实有严谨的方法。事实上，如果你是（我猜大多数人都是）软件工程师倾向的背景，或者不是那种经常与此打交道的的产品或项目经理，你可能会对我们要谈的内容感到更加自在。如果你的职业是管理项目，你可能会觉得这简直糟透了。所以我深表歉意。但是，你知道的，人们构建软件的传统方式，我想你可以称之为瀑布流。你完成第一步，把它差不多搞定，拿到你的成果，然后那会流入第二步，
then more work is done, right? You flow into step three. And if you found a problem or issue, you would go back to some previous step and sort of start over. And then once you got to the end of your waterfall, your product would be built, right? People realized that was pretty inflexible,
接着完成更多的工作，对吧？你进入第三步。如果你发现了问题或缺陷，你会回到之前的某个步骤，然后重新开始。一旦你走到了瀑布流的尽头，你的产品就构建完成了，对吧？人们意识到这种方法非常缺乏灵活性，
that requirements change, that there are issues. Then really popular was the agile method where the, as the name applies, the idea was to be more agile, to sort of get something up and working and then sort of find the next bit to be added, the next feature to be added and work in smaller units of time. So you could get feedback from your customer. And I think that had a lot of really positive impacts on the industry. I think there's a lot of cases where maybe some of the assumptions about how you could
需求会发生变化，而且会存在各种问题。于是，敏捷方法（agile method）变得非常流行。顾名思义，这种方法的理念是更具敏捷性，先弄出一些可以运行的东西，然后找出下一个要添加的位点、下一个要添加的功能，并在更短的时间单位内进行工作。这样你就可以从客户那里获得反馈。我认为这对整个行业产生了许多非常积极的影响。我认为在许多情况下，也许关于你如何能或不能获得反馈以及事情需要花费多长时间的一些假设，催生了敏捷方法的各种改编版本，也许有些人把它看得比最初的创立者所意图的还要教条。因此它也有了某种类似，你知道的，污名化。但我要说的是，至少在我合作过的人和我工作的领域中，大多数人采用的都是某种混合方法，绝对不是那种非常严谨的、带注册商标的敏捷方法论，带有全套的Scrum（敏捷开发框架）以及所有那些东西，但绝对也不是那种带有严格表现形式的传统瀑布流。我认为这两种方法都有其用武之地，也都有重要的特点，但我看到的大多数事情
or couldn't get feedback and how long stuff would take, like there were adaptations of the agile method and maybe some people took it to be more of a stricture than even the originators intended it to be. And so it got its own sort of like, you know, stigma. But what I would say is at least in the people I work with in the domains I work with, most people fall into some sort of hybrid approach, definitely not a very rigorous, you know, the agile TM, you know, methodology, with the full scrum, you know, all that stuff, but definitely not the, you know, original waterfall, you know, with its, you know, strict representation. And I think there are uses for both, and important features are both, but most of the stuff that I see happening
最终都落在了某个中间地带，融合了对两者经验的某种混合式的实际调整。但我也要说的是，在我和我目前所在的行业中，项目规划是必需的，因为我们总是需要组织性。不过与客户的互动并不是一种契约式的事务，你绝对会确保你的组织方式能够向外部进行沟通。是的，完全同意。我的意思是，我认为帕特里克和我都处于类似的职位，我们从事的是长期项目，没有那么多紧迫的SLA（服务等级协议），不会出现那种别人提了一个Issue，你必须在24小时内做出回应的情况。
falls kind of like somewhere in the middle with some hybrid practical adaptation of learnings from both. But I also will say that in the industry and current part of the industry I work in, that project planning is needed because we always need organization. But the interaction with the customer isn't a contractual thing where you would definitely, you know, want to make sure that your organization was such that it can be communicated externally. Yeah, I totally agree. I mean, I think Patrick and I both are in a similar position where we work on longer term projects that don't have a lot of like tight SLAs where there's someone, you know, someone files an issue and you have 24 hours to respond to it type thing.
所以它会带有那种倾向。但我认为，是的，我觉得帕特里克完全是对的。我的意思是，从某种意义上说，你总是有一个瀑布流，因为你想完成一些事情，比如你想搭建支架，你想构建某样东西，然后你希望下一项东西是派生的。但与此同时，你希望能够对不断发生巨大变化的环境做出反应。你知道，可能有人写了一篇研究论文，抢先发表了你的创意，现在你必须调整方向；或者他们写了一篇论文，迫使你改变做事的方式。所以你必须不断适应这种变化。因此你也需要其中一些敏捷方法，这样，你知道的，会有许多不同的考量。我的意思是，一个是，如果你最后调整了太多次，你真的很难弄清楚你到底做了什么。给人们一种安全感，让他们觉得自己在朝着一个目标前进，即使情况非常不稳定。我的意思是，这正是敏捷的优势所在。所以有一件事，无论你选择哪一种
So it's going to have that bent to it. But I think that, yeah, I think Patrick's totally right. I mean, you always have a waterfall in a sense because you want to accomplish things that, like you want to scaffold, like you want to build something and then you want the next thing to be derivative. But then at the same time, you want to be able to respond to the environment, which changes massively. You know, someone might write a research paper that scoops your idea and now you have to pivot, or they write a paper that causes you to have to change the way that you want to go about doing something. And so you have to constantly adapt to that. And so you need some of those agile methods as well so that, you know, there's a lot of different concerns. I mean, one is, you know, you adapted so many times at the end, it's really hard to know what you really did. give people this security that they're marching towards a goal, even when things are really erratic. I mean, that's what Agile is really good at. So one thing, no matter whether you choose one
这些方法，还是采用混合方法，亦或是走自己的路，项目规划中总会有几个不同的要素在每个计划中都会出现。第一件事就是人员规模（headcount）。那么，有多少人或者说有多少比例的人力时间投入到这个项目中？第二件事将是范围（scope），对吧？现在，通常对于一个项目来说，好吧，第二件事是范围，第三件事是时间，对吧？
of these approaches or you do a hybrid or you go your own route, there's going to be several different factors of project planning that are always going to come up in every plan. The first thing is headcount. So how many people or how many portions of people's time is dedicated to this project? The second one is going to be scope, right? Now, typically for a project, well, second one is going to be scope and the third one is going to be time, right?
这里有一个著名的三角形。就像是人员、范围和时间，你只能控制其中的两个。所以如果你想更快地完成事情，你可以增加更多的人；或者如果你想更快地完成事情，你可以缩小范围。但如果你这两者都不愿意做，
And there's this famous triangle. It's like headcount, scope, and time, and you can only control two of those. So if you want things done quicker, you can add more people, or if you want things done quicker, you can reduce the scope. But if you're not willing to do either of those things,
你就无法更快地完成事情。一旦你在这个三角形中固化了这三个点中的两个，那么第三个点就会自动为你决定。所以我想深入探讨这三点。因此，你的团队规模相对比较直观。我认为人员规模变得更复杂的地方在于它与其他两者的关系。也就是能够根据边际进行回答，并说，好吧，你知道的，如果我们再雇佣一个人，
you can't get things done quicker. Like once you've solidified two of those three points in that triangle, then the third one is automatically decided for you. So I guess diving into all three of these. So your headcount is relatively straightforward. I think where headcount gets more complicated is its relationship to the other two. So being able to answer at the margin and say, okay, you know, if we hired another person,
那么X就会发生，对吧？然后我们就会有X倍的范围，或者我们会快这么多周完成。这就是让人员规模这部分变得有点有趣的地方。类似于，你知道的，回答这些反事实问题（counterfactuals），你还要进行优先级排序，以便你可以朝另一个方向回答反事实问题。如果我从这个项目中抽走一个人，会发生什么？所以，我认为这正是让人员规模部分不仅仅是一个会计问题的原因。我认为关于人员规模棘手的部分，也是每个人都知道但又总是忘记的，就像杰森所说的那样，如果我有一个人，我再加一个人，我就可以完成两倍的范围或者花一半的时间。哦，不。
then X would happen, right? Then we would have X more scope, or we would be done this many weeks quicker. And so that's what makes the headcount part kind of interesting. Similar to, you know, answering these counterfactuals, you're also prioritizing so you can answer counterfactuals the other direction. If I took a person off this project, what would happen? And so that's, I think, what makes the headcount part, not just an accounting thing. I think also the tricky part about headcount, which kind of everyone knows, but everyone always forgets, is like Jason is saying, if I have one person and I add another person, I can do two times scope or half the time. Oh no.
就像，不，不，不。绝对不是这样的。是的。而且这甚至不是一个公式，对吧？这 realmente 取决于工作本身。有时当你刚开始时，你并不知道：你能轻易地把这项工作切分成段吗？沟通障碍是什么？
Like, no, no, no. That's definitely not how it works. Yeah. And it's not even an equation, right? It really depends on the work. And sometimes you don't know when you're getting started, like, can you easily segment this work? What is the communications barriers?
我认为这里面有太多的细微差别，但我发现每个人都在不断地忘记这一点。是的。而且我认为，你知道的，团队通常是异质的（heterogeneous），对吧？因此我们曾遇到这样一种情况：在一段时间内，团队中的研究科学家数量远多于工程师。所以有些高优先级的任务无法完成，尽管我们有人手，但我们没有足够类型匹配的人手。因此这也成了一个问题。甚至还有一些事情，
And I think there's just so many nuances to that, but it's something I see that everyone forgets constantly. Yep. And also, I think that, you know, the teams are usually heterogeneous, right? And so we had a situation where we ended up with way more research scientists than engineers on the team for a portion. And so there were things that couldn't get done that were high priority, even though we had the headcount, but we didn't have enough of the right type of headcount. So that becomes an issue as well. And then even there's some things that,
你必须审视团队，有些事情人们就是不想做。所以这也会成为其中的一部分，对吧？因此我认为所有这些事情都使得人员规模变得更加复杂，但我想说它是三者中最简单的。对于这一点，我通常只使用Excel电子表格。你呢，帕特里克？
you have to look at the team, there's some things that people just don't want to do. And so that becomes part of it too, right? So I think all these things make headcount a little more complicated, but I would say it's the simplest of the three. And for that, I've generally just used an Excel spreadsheet. What about you, Patrick?
你用什么工具来做人员规划？没有那么正式。我不知道它是不是一直都是这样，我想说，这不是那种我们把人招进来的单一庞大项目。情况总是这样：我们有各种各样的项目。向管理层提出的问题，有点像你刚才说的，就是：如果我能再给你一个人，
What tool do you use for headcount planning? Nothing so formal. I don't know that it's always been, I guess, not one monolithic project where we brought people on. It was always, we have a variety of projects. And the question, kind of like you're saying to management, was like, if I could get you another person,
我可以保持这个进度或者承担更多的工作。如果你抽走一个人——请千万别这么做——那么，你知道的，我们就无法完成这些事情了。所以这从来都不是必须的。对于我们来说，至少一直以来，在获取新人方面都有一个相当硬性的限制。所以秘诀永远是利用现有的资源，
I could keep this up or take on more work. If you took a person away, please don't. Then, you know, we would not be able to do these things. And so it's never required. There's always been, I guess, at least for us, like a pretty hard constraint on getting new people. So it was always make the most
做到最好。然后偶尔你取得了足够的成功，人们想要更多某种东西。接着基本上就会有人问你：如果有另一个人加入会有用吗？对。然后答案其实已经不言而喻了。是的。是的。我完全同意。是的。所以我觉得对于人员规划，你不需要任何太花哨的东西。我认为一个电子表格或谷歌文档就完全足够了。所以第二点是范围。现在对于范围来说，我认为在这里拥有（你知道的）一组工作项或你可以做的事情是非常重要的。而且你想追踪这些事情。所以我过去使用的是看板（Kanban boards）的一些变体。所以看板基本上就是——可能我也会把这个词用砸——你有不同的类别。
with what we have. And then occasionally you were successful enough that people wanted more of something. And then basically you were offered like, would it be useful to have another person? Yep. And then the answer was already kind of a given. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. I totally agree. Yeah. So I think for headcount planning, you don't need anything too fancy. I think just a spreadsheet or a Google Doc is more than enough. So the second one is scope. Now for scope, this is where I think having, you know, some set of work items or things that you could be doing. And you want to track those things. So what I've used in the past has been some variation of Kanban boards. So Kanban is basically you have, and I'm probably going to butcher this too, but you have, you know, different categories.
你有一个类别的事情，你知道的，是我们想要去做的，或者我们要去做但还没开始，不过它们迫在眉睫。你正在做的事情，已经完成的事情。然后你还有另一个类别叫做“冰柜”（icebox），也就是这些是我们还没有（你知道的）承诺要去做的东西，但它们是一些想法，我们已经……所以通常东西会被放进冰柜，而不是在冰柜里被创造出来，对吧？所以，你知道的，我大部分的范围规划都遵循了这些思路。然后对于其中的每一个项目，你都希望分配某种优先级。所以，还是那句话，回答那个问题：如果有人离开，你知道的，你要踢掉的项目是什么？毫无疑问，在不受限制的情况下，它将是优先级最低的项目。如果有新人加入，你知道的，我们可以从冰柜里把什么东西拿出来开始做？是的，基本上就是这样。问题在于人们一直在添加新的东西。如果你提前六个月做规划，你知道的，在那个计划进行到一半的时候，已经添加了一百件不同的事情。所以你必须应对范围蔓延（scope creep）。我想我来试着谈谈第三个。然后也许既然这是你的话题，你可以补充我遗漏的任何内容。但当我们谈论时间时，我想你刚才提到了，对吧，这是一个三角形。所以如果你有了人员规模和范围，那么问题就是，好吧，很好。时间是受限的，但时间到底会是多久？在这里我想说的是，至少对我而言，我发现人们很难
You have one category of things that, you know, we want to work on or things that we're going to work on, but we haven't got to yet, but they're imminent. Things that you're working on, things that are done. And then you have this other category called like the icebox, where it's, these are things that we haven't, you know, committed to working on them yet, but there are ideas that, you know, we've, so usually things get put in the icebox, they're not created in the icebox, right? And so, you know, most of my scope planning has followed along those lines. And then with each of these items, you'd want to assign some type of priority. So, again, answering that question, if somebody leaves, you know, what's the item you would kick out, you know, definitely would be the constraints notwithstanding, it would be the
记住一个人为项目实际工作的小时数与项目交付的日历日期之间的区别。所以人们会说，哦，你知道的，你问一个工程师：“做这件事需要多长时间？”他会说：“哦，我需要六个小时。”你会说：“哦，太好了。我给你安排到明天完成。”结果却发现，“哦，不，不，不是那样的。直到下周或者直到这五个依赖项到位之前，我不会花六个小时去做这个。”所以说时间是正确的，但确实有点含糊不清。
lowest priority item. And if people join, you know, what things from the icebox could we bring and start working on? Yeah, that's effectively how it goes. The issue is people are constantly adding new things. If you're planning six months in advance, you know, halfway through that plan, there's a hundred different things that have been added. So there's a scope creep that you have to deal with. I guess I'll try to tackle the third one. And then maybe since it was yours, you can follow up with whatever I missed. But when we talk about time, I think you were mentioning, right, like this is a triangle. So if you have headcount and scope, then like, sort of the question is, okay, well, fine. Time is constrained, but what is the time going to be? And I'll call it here that for me, at least I find it very difficult for people to
还有，当我们讨论你确定了范围，然后现在你说时间，所以你只是试着把功能定义好，但实现该功能的耗时总是存在变数。所以人们会做“T恤尺码估算”（t-shirt sizing），这是一个小型、中型还是大型项目？你可以采取这些方法并把它们汇总，给它们打分，然后说分数不重要。但接着某人会有一套评分细则，规定多少分等于多少小时。事情总是以这种方式结束。我挺想尝试的一个有趣的讨论是：如果你把所有需要做的事情按顺序排列，并且你的估算不仅基于你认为平均需要多长时间，还基于你对这个时间的把握有多大。换句话说，每一项都有一定的不确定性。那么你可以把它们汇总并得出最小值和最大值，对吧？所以如果某事需要一周，正负一天，然后另一件事需要两周，正负五天，你可以把所有这些以及所有的正负值汇总起来，你会得到一个荒谬的结果：我将会在一个月到一年之间的某个时间完成，对吧？就像这样，这不会超级有用。或者你可以怎么做呢——我看到有人说过——就是玩一下蒙特卡洛模拟（Monte Carlo），从这些分布中抽样，然后实际展示出：哦，绝大部分，如果你
remember the distinction between the number of hours a person can work the project versus what calendar date the project will be delivered on. And so people will say, oh, you know, you ask an engineer, how long would it take you to do this thing? And I'll say, oh, it takes me six hours. He's like, okay, well, cool. I'll put it down for you to have tomorrow. And it's like, well, no, no, that's not how that works. I'm not going to work six hours until next week or until these five dependencies come in. And so saying time is correct, but yeah, a little bit ambiguous.
假设它们是正态分布的还是别的什么。然后你抽取每一个这些顺序排列的事物并做一个堆叠，你随机进行选择并查看结果。你会发现95%的情况下你将会在大约六个月（正负一周）内完成，对吧？
And then also, when we talk about you've had scope and then now you say time so you just try to define the feature well but there's always variability to how long it's going to take to implement that feature and so you know people do oh it's t-shirt sizing is it a small medium or large uh you know project and you can take those approaches and try to roll them up, give them points, say the points don't matter. But then someone has a rubric for how many points equals how many hours. It always kind of ends up that way. And an interesting discussion I kind of want to try is if you sequence out all the things that you need to do and your estimate for not just how long you think they
这样你就可以传达出该分布的离散程度（spread）大概是什么样的，形状大概是什么样的，而不仅仅是极值。然后人们就可以在某种程度上内化这种分布的离散程度是什么样的，形状是什么样的，而不仅仅是边界。接着人们就可以在某种程度上内化：哦，随着期限临近，你会期望它收窄，而且，嘿，他们最终在承诺日期的两周内完成，这其实是非常合理的，他们干得不错。我从没见过有人愿意玩这个游戏，但它听起来很有趣。是的，这确实说得通。我的意思是，我认为高层级的做法绝对是记录下这类互动。
would take on average, but how sure you are about that time. So in other words, there's some uncertainty on each, then what you could kind of roll up and get the minimum and maximum, right? So if something takes one week, plus or minus a day, and then something else takes two weeks, plus or minus five days, you could roll all those up and all those plus or minuses, and you get some absurd, I'll finish somewhere between one month and one year, right? Like you're going to, it's going to be not super useful. Or what you could do, which I saw someone saying is, is sort of play some Monte Carlo, you know, drawing from those distributions and actually show like, oh, the bulk, if you
所以如果你长期预算过高或过低，你希望能够适应这一点。你不想只是像那样——继续以递归的方式沦为你自己幻觉的牺牲品。就像你预算过高，然后差不多忘了自己预算过高。接着，嗯，你知道的，没有人被解雇。然后下一个半年度，你把过高的预算翻倍，对吧？所以你实际上需要有那种核算机制，这样你才能说：“哦，不，我其实以为我们在这一半年度能完成更多工作。我需要意识到这一点，并在下次做出调整。”
assume that they're normally distributed or not. And then you drew each of these, you know, sequential things and did a stack up and you're randomly choosing and then looked at the outcomes. What you'll find is 95% of the time you're going to finish, you know, around six months plus or minus a week, right?
另一件非常重要的事情——你刚才在谈到时间时暗示了这一点——就是依赖关系（dependencies），对吧？所以如果某件事需要一天，但你在等待另一个团队，那么它就需要一天加上那个团队完成你所等待的事情所需的时间。那可能是一个月，也可能是一年，对吧？所以在时间追踪中，对于项目时间追踪，最好使用甘特图（Gantt chart）。如果你没见过甘特图，它是一种表示事件图表的方式。所以那些依赖于
And then that way you can kind of communicate what the spread of that distribution kind of looks like, what the shape looks like, not just the extents. And then people can kind of internal what the spread of that distribution kind of looks like, what the shape looks like, not just the extent. And then people can kind of internalize like, oh, as it gets closer, you would expect it to narrow in and, you know, hey, that they landed, you know, two weeks out from what they said is actually perfectly reasonable. They did a good job, you know, I've never seen someone be willing to play this game, but it sounded interesting. Yeah, no, it makes sense. I mean, I think the high level thing is to definitely record these kind of interactions.
其他事件的事件会在那些事件结束时开始。甘特图的工作方式就是，你知道的，任何可以立即完成的事情都从时间t等于零开始；然后当这些事情结束时，现在变得可行的新事情就会在那些事情结束时开始。所以你可以大致看出，如果你——甘特图的工作方式是，你知道的，如果你拥有无限的人力，而你的目标只是遍历这些项目，无论它们花多长时间，整个项目就会花这么长时间。有些事情可能只需要一点时间，它们在这个甘特图上可能只是非常微小的间隔，但它们可能会非常遥远地排在未来，因为它们依赖于太多其他的事情。所以，是的，我的意思是，我认为项目规划中的时间部分可能是最重要的，因为特别是如果其他团队——
So if you're chronically over budgeting or under budgeting, you want to be able to adapt to that. You don't want to just like continue to sort of like recursively fall victim to like your own hallucinations. It's like you over budget and it'd be kind of forgot you over budgeted. And then, well, you know, nobody got fired. And then next half, like you double the over budget, right? So you want to actually have that accounting so you can say, oh, no, I actually thought we were going to get a lot more done this half. And I need to sort of like, you know, realize that and pivot for next time.
比方说另一个团队，假设你有一个你认为需要三个月的项目，而你的整个项目计划是六个月，但它依赖于某个东西。然后那个东西晚了四个月到来。好吧，现在，你提前知道了，
Another thing that's really important, you alluded to this with time is the dependencies, right? So if something's going to take a day, but you're waiting on another team, then it's going to take a day plus however long that team takes to do that thing that you're waiting on. And that could be a month, it could be a year, right? And so for time tracking, for project time tracking, it's good to use a Gantt chart, which a Gantt chart, if you haven't seen it, it's a way of representing sort of a graph of events. And so the events that depend
你要延期了。就像你知道的那样，你无法按时完成，因为你没能在正确的时间开始。
on other ones start when those events end and so the way the gantt works is you know anything that can be done right away just starts at time t equals zero and then when those things end the new things that are now possible start when those things end and so you can kind of see you know if if you had the way the gantt chart works is you know if you had effectively infinite head count and your goal is to just like go through these items, taking however long they take, this is how long the whole thing is going to take. And some things that might only take a little bit of time, they might be really tiny intervals on this Gantt chart, but they might be way out into the future because they depend on so many other things. So yeah, I mean, I think the timing part of project planning might be the most important because especially if other teams,
这里只是一个元观点（meta point），但依我之见，你总是希望尽快宣告你的失败。是的。这就是我的，好吧。你同意我的看法吗？因为这就是我对这件事的看法。我其实还没问过其他人对这件事的看法，但，但是的，我的意思是，如果某件事在两个月后会失败而你知道这一点，你就会想要——我是说，不是向全世界宣告，比如给公司里的每个人写一封电子邮件说：“嘿，我是个失败者。”这不是运作方式。你想告诉利益相关者：这还有六个月，而我现在就已经告诉你这不会发生了，
let's say another team, let's just say you have a project that you think is going to take three months and your whole project plan is six months, but it depends on something. And then that thing comes four months, you know, four months late. Well, now, you know, in advance, um, that you're going to be late. Like, you know, that you can't get that done in time because you weren't able to start at the right time.
原因就是这样。你想快点这样做。而项目规划，尤其是作为一个动态文档，会在你需要的时候为你提供这些信息。是的，我的意思是，我觉得这里有很多我们可以深入探讨的内容，比如关于风险和关键路径（critical path）。而我们真的快没时间了。
Just kind of a meta point here, but, um, in my opinion, you always want to, um, announce your failures as soon as possible. Yes. That's my, yeah. Okay. You agree with me on this? Cause this is my opinion on it. I haven't actually asked anybody else's opinion on this yet, but, but yeah, I mean, if something is going to fail two months from now and you know it, you want to, I mean, not announce to the whole world, like write an email to, you know, everyone at company, Hey, I'm a failure. Like's not how it works. You want to tell the stakeholders, this, it's six months out, and I'm already telling you it's not going to happen,
所以我们必须快速浏览这些内容。但我的意思是，你所说的完全正确，杰森，在你看到你需要经历的功能转换之前，你无法知道你应该分解、消除风险（de-risk）、提前进行或并行化哪些部分。
and this is why. You want to do that quickly. And project planning, especially a living document, will give you that information when you need it. Yeah, I mean, I think there's a whole thing we could get into here that talks about like risk and the critical path. And we're like really running out of time.
这将花费最长的时间，从而决定这一点；而且如果你进度超前——这似乎永远不会发生——那么，好吧，祝你好运。其他东西可以进入之前不在关键路径上的路径，或者如果某些事情拖延得更久，你需要知道它在什么时候从不在关键路径上转移到关键路径上，以及延迟了多少时间。所以甘特图在某种程度上被低估了，而在另一方面，在某些情况下又过于教条了，但其中存在一个平衡点，它是一个非常实用的工具。是的，我想总结一下，有几件事。首先，不要太沉迷于工具。刚开始时，我看过《Manager Tools》播客，我意识到的是，工具其实并没有那么重要。
So we have to zip through these things. But I mean, I think what you're saying is exactly right, Jason, that you can't know what parts you should decompose or de-risk or bring forward earlier, parallelize until you sort of see like what the transition of features you need to go through
你可以使用电子表格，也可以手写在笔记本上，工具会有所帮助。但除非你的工作整天都是做项目规划，你知道的，如果你每周花比方说五小时或十小时做项目规划，
that is going to take longest and therefore determine and also if you run ahead of schedule which seems to never happen then like yeah good luck else can move into the critical path that wasn't before or if something stretches longer you need to know when it moves from off to on the critical path at what time delay and so a Gantt chart is really in some ways underutilized and other words, overly prescriptive in some cases, but there is a balance there where it's a very useful tool. Yeah. I guess to wrap this up, a couple of things. One thing is don't get too caught up on tools. When I started, I mean, I was looking at the manager tools podcast and what I realized was the tools actually aren't that important.
工具并不会从那五到十个小时中为你省掉太多时间，对吧？所以，工具不会从那五到十个小时中为你省掉太多时间，对吧？所以不要太担心工具。关键在于构建这些流程并获得经验。关于项目规划的最后一件事是，要意识到时间尺度，
Like you can use a spreadsheet, you can write it by hand in a notebook and the tools will help. But unless you're project planning, you know, all day as your job, you know, if you're spending, let's say five hours a week or 10 hours a week project planning,
并认识到我要提及的所有这三个尺度出于不同的原因都很重要。所以在短期内，比方说，未来两周或一个月，你需要有非常清晰的工作包（work packages）。这样，你知道的，人们是有生产力的。你知道的，人们不会感到沮丧。如果有人不堪重负，你也能及时知道。所以这就是——我们称之为敏捷会把这些称为冲刺（sprints），对吧。但是，实际上，你可以把它看作是一个短期，
the tools aren't going to shave that much time off of those five or 10 hours, right? So, the tools aren't going to shave that much time off of those five or 10 hours, right? So don't worry too much about the tools. It's really about building those processes and gaining that experience. One last bit about project planning is to be cognizant of the timescale
你知道的，敏捷会把那些称为冲刺，对吧？但实际上你可以把它看作是短期内，比如几周到一个月。你希望在中期内，比方说六个月，拥有里程碑，或者也许一年，你希望拥有里程碑。你希望能够有一个“国情咨文”（state of the union）式的状态，让你能够反思并说：“好吧，在过去的六个月里，我们的团队完成了这些事情。然后在接下来的六个月里，我们要完成那些事情。”你希望真正地广播这一点、宣告这一点，并将其作为团队精神的一部分。所以这是在中期。现在，长期则是展望未来三、四年。你可能会问：“为什么我甚至需要一个长期愿景？”而且，你知道的，特别是如果你在做研究，或者你在从事某些工作，或者你在做一个处于维护模式的项目。
and recognize that all three of these scales I'm gonna mention are important for different reasons. So in the short term, so let's say, you know, two weeks or a month ahead, you want to have very clear kind of work packages. So, you know, people are being productive. You know, people aren't frustrated. If someone's overwhelmed that you know about that as well. And so that's, you know, we call it the agile would call those sprints. Right. But but effectively, you think of it as like a short term, you know, we call it, the agile would call those sprints, right? But
就像，为什么你需要一个三四年期的愿景？我想答案是：
effectively you think of it as like the short term, you know, a couple of weeks to a month. You want to have in the medium term, let's say six months, you want to have milestones or maybe a year you want to have milestones. And you want to be able to have sort of a state of the union where you kind of reflect and say, okay, in the past six months, our team has done these things. And then the next six months, we're going to do these other things. And you want to really broadcast that and announce that and make that part of the ethos of your team. And so that's in the medium term. Now, the long term is looking out maybe three years, four years. And you might say, well, why do I even need a long term vision? And, you know, especially if you're doing, let's say, research or you're working on some or you're doing some project that's in maintenance mode.
因为最终，你的项目规划和你的某种文化将开始融合在一起。你设定的那个长期愿景也将为你项目或团队中拥有的文化和环境定下基调。所以，即使你的长期愿景——三年后我们要搞什么研究，这可能很难说清楚——从实际意义上讲，没有办法知道你会真正利用那个长期愿景来描述你的整体哲学，以及你可以对你想让它去的未来产生的宏伟愿景（delusions of grandeur）。因此，根据你如何构建它，
Like, why do you need a three year, four year vision? And I think the answer is. Because ultimately, your project planning and your sort of culture will start to kind of blend together. And you're setting that long term vision will also kind of set the kind of culture and the kind of environment that you're going to have on your in your project or on your team. And so even if your long-term vision, it might be hard to say three years from now, you know, what research are we going to do? Like practically speaking, there's no way to know that you're really going to use that long-term vision to describe kind of your overall philosophy and sort of delusions of grandeur that you can create about the future where you want it to go. And so depending on how you structure that,
它将在某种程度上引导那些有兴趣参与该项目的人。有一个人曾用一种非常好的方式对我说过：基本上就是说，某人将对某件拥有巨大回报的事情承担某种巨大的风险。所以那个长期愿景是一种向人们展示这种巨大回报的方式，这样他们就会觉得他们正在投入一件具有巨大体量的事情中。所以我认为这三者都超级重要。再次强调，不要太担心技术，但我们希望在这里给出了很多关于如何有效地做到这一点以及这些事情如何相互作用的好建议。太棒了。这真的很有趣。
it will kind of guide the people who are interested in working on that project. I think a person put it to me in a really good way. It basically said, you know, someone's going to take a sort of big risk on something that has a big reward. And so that long-term vision is a way to sort of show that big reward to people so that they feel like they're jumping into something that has a lot of mass. So I think all three of them are super important. Again, don't worry too much about the tech, but we gave hopefully a lot of good tips here on how to do that effectively and how those things interplay. Nice. That was really fun.
它将引导那些有兴趣参与该项目的人。我觉得一个人用一种很好的方式向我表达了这一点。它基本上是说，你知道的，有人会对一个有巨大回报的事情冒巨大的风险。因此，这种长期愿景是一种向人们展示巨大回报的方式，让他们觉得他们正在投入一件很有分量的事情中。所以我认为这三者都超级重要。再次强调，不要太担心技术，但我们在这里希望就如何有效地做到这一点以及这些事物如何相互作用提供了很多好的建议。太好了。这真的很有趣。
Cool. All right, everyone. Thanks again for supporting the show on Patreon. We really appreciate it. And hope you all like the transcripts that we were able to add and the variety of other features that us, our producers have been putting together. Thanks again for listening and we'll catch y'all in a couple of weeks. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0
太棒了。好了，各位。再次感谢大家在 Patreon 上对本节目的支持。我们非常感激。希望大家喜欢我们添加的文稿以及我们的制作人们精心策划的各种其他功能。再次感谢大家的收听，我们几周后见。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。《Programming Throwdown》采用知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0
license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
许可协议分发。您可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输本作品，以及混音、改编本作品，但您必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。